foreign
pretty good yeah okay
okay I'd like to go ahead and and get
ourselves organized here so we can get
on with the hearing schedule for today
uh prior to getting into the hearing
process I'd like to look at calendar and
try to give some folks here notice of
when we may be meeting whether it's
getting nicer and I know folks would
like to be out
thinking about gardening
although I woke up to an inch of snow
and ice over everything this morning so
it was not not great driving so
this room is going to be used
by another committee on the 4th and 12th
of April so that means everything we
have in the table tops here has to be
cleaned off
and and so we do the fact that we have
so few bills I think it's only 14 bills
or so that I can count so far
a better knock on wood here
um that we won't be using this room
consistently every day of the week like
we have in the past just about and so it
will be shared
um so on the fourth and 12th it will be
used so we need to clean it off now in
terms of what we're doing with the rest
of the schedule here on the sixth course
you know that's crossover and that's
going to be the day which the budget is
resolved uh so that's that's Thursday of
next week but the following week on the
11th I'm looking at doing a session
which we're going to be exacting some of
those bills if we we will have heard
that are Senate bills and possibly also
taking the 13th that's a Thursday I
don't think there's going to be a
session that week
so it be the Tuesday and the Thursday of
the following week if we can get some of
this done that leaves us just the 18th
in which we have a hearing on uh 2272 I
believe in reps Hall
and we will also have the bill which we
didn't address yesterday that will be
carried forward and we have to exact
that or or hear that somewhere along the
way here
um I I don't intend to really
um
try to do something on the 18th unless
that we look at that bill we know we can
get it down quickly maybe do it just
prior to the the opening of what we do
in Repsol you might be able to do it on
that date
so I'm trying to set it up so the last
two weeks or so of April we won't have
to be here as much and that's when you
know the the robin should be back in the
Red Wing blackbirds and all that good
stuff that wake you up at four o'clock
in the morning
so if your windows open so so I'm I'm
trying to set it up so we will have some
time here in April it's a wonderful
night I'm not not to have to do so much
driving down to Concord or up to conquer
so any questions on on the on the
scheduling of events
dates for 13th
the 11th and the 13th that's a Tuesday
and a Thursday would you just you know
if you're scheduling appointments just
try to keep them clear so that we can
use those two days to exact bills which
we have done here the other day and
we're going to be doing today
and then on the on I don't know if you
were here representative Cornell that we
have this room being used on the fourth
and the 12th and so we got to clean off
our desktops make sure nothing's left
here
okay any other questions about calendar
thank you so with that I'd like to get
into today's hearings here and the the
first one which we have in the docket is
H SB 39 that's a FN bill it's relative
to criminal history checks for school
transportation monitors and Grant are
you yeah Grant bossy is here for Senator
Gannon uh who is obviously busy
elsewhere and so Grant thank you very
much for introducing the bill
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee always pleasure to be
back before the house education
committee I'm Grant bossy Deputy Chief
of Staff for the New Hampshire Senate uh
pinch hitting here on opening day for
Senator Bill Gannon he for people who've
asked he is out of the ICU uh feeling
much better he hopes to be back next
week uh today is also our Senate
crossover day so our Senators will be on
the floor most of the day so you'll be
getting me uh pretty much all morning
SB 39 would fix a gap in our background
check system protecting children in New
Hampshire schools in 2020 the
legislature moved the responsibility for
performing criminal background checks on
Transportation monitors out of the
Department of education's Education
credentialing system and over to the
Division of Motor Vehicles however DMV
actually doesn't have any licensing
authority over Transportation monitors
these are parents or volunteers who go
along on school field trips or uh
sports games
these background checks ended up not
being conducted by anyone SB 39 would
put Transportation monitors back in RSA
18913 to ensure that people with
disqualifying criminal histories are not
coming into contact with New Hampshire
students the Department of Education is
here should be able to answer any
questions you have if you have any
questions for Senator Gannon I can get
them to him Senator again and thanks you
for your consideration and support of
Senate Bill 39 thank you thank you very
much
um so I don't think it's necessary that
we ask Grant questions uh he is here
conveying for Senator again and
um uh let's ask Diane do you have are
you able to give any technical support
on this if we need it
if it's needed so are there any
questions
from the committee that the department
might be able to help you out on yes
representative Cornell Thank you um I I
think he said it would be volunteers on
buses and to me Transportation monitors
are the people that perhaps are paid to
be on the bus to monitor like special ed
buses or something
could you clear that up
Transportation monitors are paid
individuals either by the district or by
the school bus company to be on the bus
volunteers are set out under the statute
um for their own background check
districts can designate they can call
them designated volunteers for this
any other questions yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so just to clarify what you just said
which contrasts with what I'm sorry I
missed the name of the gentleman who
introduced the bill Grant bossy this
does not change any RSA related to
parent volunteers this is addressing the
paid Transportation monitors
that are in my understanding sort of
employed to do Behavioral Management on
[Laughter]
yes represent Cascade
so just to clarify
um so there's no statute that covers
someone who's riding the bus either as a
paid person or a volunteer
because I would think if the school was
putting a volunteer on a bus
they would get a criminal background
check based on the volunteer policy
if they were paid by the district they'd
get criminal background check based on
an employee
and if the bus company is required to
have
criminal background check and they hire
a transportation monitor wouldn't that
fall under that auspice
or do they have to to me the those two
entities should cover a transportation
monitor do I I think they should be
criminal check absolutely but does it
need a specific title
that's different than an employee or a
volunteer
we're pulled out
pulled out because we wanted to have a
Statewide certification yeah which
allowed them
the fund that allows them that Mobility
when they did that
um we recognized that the Department of
Education and the department of safety
DMV would both be checking
bus route bus drivers are held from a
they tacked on Transportation monitors
come on we pulled out bus drivers the
natural inclination would put
Transportation monitors with
Buster in the statute okay okay the
problem with that
the department had no oversight on
Transportation
they don't supervise them they have no
oversight
and so when we went to work on this new
law with our partners in the Department
of Motor Vehicles we realized
we
right they are as you said it should be
an employment issue but by calling it
out and putting it in a 189 13c we took
mm-hmm
right
really playing with you
okay great thanks
representative Myler uh thank you and
Dan I might want to turn your mic on too
um so now that if this comes back to the
department Under The Spill who then does
coming back to the department right now
it's under the purview of the department
we're trying to say it's an employment
issue
and have it go back to the to the
district so the district then conducts
it that's correct it would be an
employment issue yeah thank you
are there questions of the department
yes representative Tanner thank you
um so do any transportation companies
so
the bus drivers are now subject to the
clearance issued by the Department of
Education
that is only looking for those section
five disqualifying
offenses that would prohibit them from
being unemployment
the transportation monitors the district
can run those individuals and make that
determination is that person right for
our district and let the bus companies
know
yes this is someone we want to have
employed or no it's not
and we've done that previously with bus
drivers
and the problem with that was that if
you were working in a couple of
different districts
yeah you could have different results
and you you had to go through a series
of different checks
potentially yes and so we put the bus
drivers yes so that they get one and it
covers them all now we've got somebody
riding on the bus that's employed by the
bus company that
has to get
checks all over the place again
possibly
I don't know if that's going to be a
is it possible to write this so that
every three years you have to have this
done that's correct if you're a monitor
and and so is it possible that it could
be written such that if it's done
through one District may go through this
check then that would be good for all
districts that person might be employed
the problem is employment is handled by
the district
and each district
each district
has has the right pursuant to the
statute as written to to have their own
policy when it comes to employment and
what they look for and
representative cascadden might have
looked for different offenses than uh
the neighboring district and every
district has that ability and that right
so there's not a reciprocity sort of
thing in regard if it's good here it's
also good there
we have it with the bus drivers we have
we have a solution as it pertains to bus
drivers the department of education
issues that clearance and that clearance
is valid throughout the state
however again Transportation monitors
are not governed by the Department of
Motor Vehicles so putting them in 189
13c
and having the Department of Motor
Vehicle have oversight doesn't work
because they don't have oversight of
Transportation right
um thank you could a couple districts
which is very common would work together
to have a monitor in a particular bus
share the cost
but be the employee of one district and
the other District pays the district for
the cost of that service
is that
there's no reason why that couldn't
happen right sure that could be a local
issue and have an mou that right governs
the terms of that but that wouldn't be
reviewed or overseen by the Department
of Education nor would you want it to be
right but so this that could happen
that's yeah I mean certainly it's
similar like to a Cooperative right
where you bring all these resources
together
yes representative Damon
thank you again
so is there anything in this proposed
legislation that prohibits
a district from
utilizing the background check that
yes
so it it does not not this proposed
legislation
but the current law prohibits that
because that's a very dangerous practice
to get into
um
first and foremost I think and I I'm not
here to testify on behalf of the
Department of Safety but the department
of safety has been here enough that you
are familiar with that term well yeah
oh my gosh they're always here when I
hear you
um I could feel someone staring at me
um
stale records
stale records that's a term that they
use they
um the concern is relying on Old
information
and when you look at employment
the law allows for each district to say
you have your list of disqualifying
offenses that are applicable throughout
the state but then each district can
have their own policy that talks about
what they look for in their own district
and so if I'm a superintendent if I rely
on someone else's judgment
and saying well they were good enough
for that District so they must be good
enough for me
that's going to violate this law because
the law is written says that each
individual district has to go through
this analysis
and decide what works for them I think
it's a liability and and I can tell you
if I was advising a district I would
shudder at the thought of relying on
oh well another District said this
person was okay so we'll take them on as
well
um
you would be opening yourself up to
massive liability
but that's why no one likes to hang out
with a lawyer because we we say things
like that
um
you all say different things too it's
true we do reps and Damon
one of my best friends is a lawyer my
forgive them I I don't know how to ask
this but it's all right so why
why don't we have
um consistency like
maybe I'm naive here but it seems to me
that the same
concern should apply across all the
districts like obviously you don't want
to murder or driving your school bus or
being your bus monitor for a you know
sure more dramatic example I know there
are nuances but
I guess I just don't understand why it's
so different from District to District
that's okay
um
I think in theory your idea works
in theory there should be a list of
offenses that say this person this makes
this person safe this makes this person
unsafe
but the reality is is there are in
countless
crimes out there and reasons behind
those crimes that make up an individual
criminal record and I think
superintendents it is a challenge for
them if that's a fair statement but they
enjoy the opportunity to weigh it out
because it's not a black and white issue
there are people behind this and so I
have
spoken with many superintendents who
will say you know what this offense uh
came up on the record it's not a
disqualifier and I want to find out more
about it I want to have the opportunity
to talk to the person to put it into
context
right when did the offense happen
how old was the person what have they
learned from it
right what does this look like and you
can't do that on any chart or graph
you have to talk to the person uh and I
think that's why
coming up with a list of offenses you're
never going to be able to
adequately do that because there's just
so much to take into consideration
I think the section five disqualifiers
is a really good start
it's it's that basic level and then
after that
um
it becomes personal it's a judgment call
it's a moral compass call and it's it
lies with the superintendent to weigh
everything out and make that ultimate
decision
and in my experience they're very
thoughtful about it
thank you and is this similar to a
substitute teacher that's not certified
you know we have many substitutes to
come in and don't have certification but
they're on the substitute list in
District A B C D and you have a hard
time getting them because I'm engaged at
e today
you know but I need you over here in a
uh so it is that background check on
that person that's done by are those
mousse or agreements or how it is
between one District to another is there
something already in place for Subs that
maybe we could use for monitors
uh I I like where you're going with that
we don't have an infrastructure for
substitute teachers
if that's what you're asking is there
some infrastructure that we can use
between districts well I'm saying is
there an infrastructure that's
established by policy at the local that
the the board or the administrator the
superintendent make you know
superintendent the superintendent
um
[Laughter]
special guest star local control huh
represent Tanner thank you so I'm still
um
kind of going back and forth on
that that it is an employment issue but
that there are two possible people that
employ these people these Transportation
monitors one is the bus company
yes and that that may that probably well
not probably but may and then you have
the school district that made
so if the bus company hires these
monitors
um
and the monitors actually fluctuate
between because a lot of the bus
companies have like two or three school
districts that they do
uh
and maybe the bus monitor that's always
been on bus five for Berlin is sick that
day and so the company says oh yeah
we'll send
Joe over to cover that bus route but the
superintendent hasn't really
had it you know any information about
that person in terms of criminal
background checks I mean who's who's
liable if something happens is it is it
the bus company that's liable and should
should they I mean is it
their job then to do criminal background
checks employment checks on everybody
that's that's a bus monitor and if
they're a bus monitor even if they're a
volunteer at Berlin they go through the
bus company or vice versa that all the
bus monitors have to go through
the superintendent or the The Local
District I mean I just can't see how you
can do it
with
with two different groups and and as you
said the liability is you know a pro is
the the bottom line really
it is always a consideration so keep in
mind
um a bus company a private company
does not have access to the FBI
background check
we've talked about that in this
committee before
even if they were
patients
they can't get back down my
understanding in my work with the
Department of Safety and this
legislative bodies work with the
Department of Safety is there is a huge
difference between a governmental entity
and a non-governmental entity and so to
put it plainly state agency or a school
district can get that FBI which is the
federal background check a private
company Diana's bus company Diana's
whatever lunch services
I I cannot get access to that
um and and that is one of the factors
that caused all these issues going back
six seven years when we started looking
at this issue
the Department of Education is in a
unique position as is a school district
because we can have that FBI background
check a private company cannot so Butler
bus service will defer to the school
district and the reason they do that is
because they get information that the
private company does not and that
information is critical in making a
and I wish it was different but
but it goes beyond my purview to the FBI
regulations
and that's not something that we're able
to change
this reference representative Ford
thank you Mr chairman uh
is there possibly
a built-in conflict between
I guess you'd call them competing
interest in this in business that
prevent people from moving and
employment I'm thinking of speech and
language Pathologists who maybe were
trained out of state license out of
state had background chases out of the
state and when they come to New
Hampshire they won't let them work until
they've had a background check but they
can't a background check is meaningless
because they haven't lived here for the
last several years
so there's nothing to background check
and you can't work without a background
check
I would disagree with that because you
can get the the federal the national
background check
and so even if they haven't lived here
um there might be information that's
critical to an employment decision well
my daughter found that they rejected her
Pennsylvania background check which was
done by valid authorities there and she
hadn't lived here long enough for a
local person to do a background check
so she couldn't work
well I'm sorry to hear that that must
have been very frustrating well very
frustrating for her because she was
trained and needed and couldn't work
so what are we going to do about it
well I I we have a possible response
right here in the form of this bill are
there any other questions regarding this
bill to Diana
thank you thank you very much
I don't have any other cards on this so
I'm going to close the hearing on SBE 39
and we're ready to start here
on 109.
okay because uh session is
in session for the the Senators we have
Senator Lang here and he's gone to he's
the prime sponsor of 109 that's relative
to school safety and coordination with
law enforcement welcome Senator thank
you uh chairman thank you members of the
committee it's fun to be back in the
house again for at least for a brief
moment
um I'm introducing Senate Bill 109
Senate Bill 109 came at the request of a
school district
um I'm going to give you a short and
easy version of the bill there was just
an issue with law enforcement
cooperating with the school district in
terms of a disciplinary matter for a
student they felt that because charges
were brought and there was a pending
criminal case or a pending juvenile case
they couldn't share the data with the
school district who was seeking to
discipline the child
um the the student in in that case
um and so what this bill does was to
clarify the fact that law enforcement
can share records with the school
district for the purposes of
communicating if those you like me who
served on the school board you know that
student display managers are held in
non-public sessions so to allow law
enforcement be able to come in and help
during a non-public session when they're
disciplining a student so they have the
accurate and complete data
um in order to carry out any possible
disciplinary action there was an
amendment done in the Senate because
there was some conversation around the
federal family education rights and
privacy acts so we amended the bill to
come into compliance with that federal
act to make sure we weren't violating
any federal law it's a pretty
straightforward we also amended the bill
to make sure that we weren't talking
about medical records only law
enforcement records and law enforcement
conversation
so I'm happy to take any questions again
this is an effort to make our schools
safe and allow our school district to be
able to take a proper just for reactions
for students who fall outside uh the
rules
thank you very much are there any
is he any hands up anywhere no no
represent cascadden yes
so are you saying that this does not
occur
So currently there's a there was a I'll
call it a conflict in law or at least a
conflict and opinion of Law and that
they there was some officers felt they
could not share the data if there was a
pending action on the student in courts
so this clarifies that they can in fact
share data regardless of the pending
action
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so
does this pertain to a
action that the student took within the
school or just in life
so I'll leave it there's a
superintendent who asked me to bring it
can explain what explain what when in
that situation that causes to come
forward I actually don't know if it
occurred between school hours or after
school hours but it was related to the
school I'm not sure I don't mean that
particular incident that precipitated
the legislation I mean the way the law
now reads
would there be communication about a
student's potential legal issues
in regards to something that may have
happened anywhere at any time or is it
limited to things that happened in
school because I don't believe it's
limited to just things that happen in
school because again things that happen
outside of school can be just as
dangerous to what happens inside school
later thank you
representative Ford thank you Mr thank
you for taking my question we're all
painfully aware of the horrible tragedy
in Tennessee and it seems to have been
at least in part affected by lack of
communication of certain kinds of
information
uh not drawing any conclusions about
that but wondering how
this law might remedy the terrible lack
of information that contributed to that
particular tragedy uh should such a
situation evolve in New Hampshire
so thank you for the question again I
guess what I'd say is this allows
communication between law enforcement
and the schools to be able to do
something so again if the law
enforcement feels that there's a
potential threat to the schools they can
communicate with the school and and act
that way or vice versa if the school has
recognizes something they may
communicate with law enforcement that
that Communications can continue to
happen
um uh during the during the out until
they get to an outcome even though it
might affect the confidentiality of
certain information normally
correct so again disciplinary matters
occur if you're again if you're serving
a school board those are always
non-public sessions when you're dealing
with disciplinary actions involving a
student or discussion involving a
student those are non-public sessions
thank you very much further questions
from the committee yes represent dry
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question
um I'm following up on what
representative Damon said the first
paragraph says that this is this allows
the exchange of information relating
only to acts of theft destruction or
violence in a safe school zone in
regarding now so
the discussion between the school and
the police when only law enforcement
only take place when there was something
that had happened at the school but the
information that shared could be of
things that have not happened in the
school area so again we what we don't
want to do is if there's a philanthropy
phase of History
um of of violence we'll use that as a
violent act that occurs in school and
there's a sub there's a previous act
that happened outside the school we
wouldn't want to limit law enforcement
say making believe that that action that
occurred within the school zone was the
only incident that ever happened right
it's important for the school to
understand what's going on so that they
can take appropriate it well it it's a
aggravating and mitigating factors for
you understand what I mean by that what
I mean is that again if it's a single
incident there may be different display
action taken than if the student has a
history of violence both inside school
yes go ahead
it's predicated by an incident in the
school that opened the whole that
started the conversation thank you
further further questioning from the
committee
thank you very much Senator and have a
thank you very much I'm representative
Tim Horrigan from uh Stratford County
District 10 the town of Durham so are
you getting a a bipartisan bicameral uh
subsection of the Tim caucus uh here
today
um
so I was uh I got involved in this bill
because uh I really like the original
version that uh represent Lang I mean
well Senator Lang introduced um in the
Senate and they um
and I think they they weakened it uh in
my mind they well they certainly uh made
it uh they certainly reduce the scope of
what it did I think because um
like the way I read the original build
it which is not performed but I think it
would have empowered schools to
coordinate with any law enforcement
official not just New Hampshire
officials when there's a threat to
student safety and that would have
included federal law enforcement as well
as other states officials um
according to other states officials as
uh useful especially in the western part
of the state where there is you well
know Mr chair there's many school
districts whose student bodies across
the Connecticut River then there's
that situation also exists on the Main
and Massachusetts borders but anyway
what the Senate passed is very good and
I think it's very useful and uh thank
you Senator you have a good explanation
of why
why what we have is good
um I was a sponsors many of you some of
you might wear HP 78 which would have
overturned uh last year's HP 1178 and
that my mind was an overly broad bill
with many bad consequences the most
egregious one was that it prevented
local prevents local law enforcement
taking proactive action when an
individual uh well violates the federal
safe schools acts and probably also like
file you know in dangers the school
Community by carrying a firearm on a
school property with permission and
that's especially near the top of the
mind at Durham because we
uh side in fact we're a college town so
that's their you know campus violence is
a threat that we're all worried about in
Durham but also we recently built a new
um it's a very beautiful new middle
school but what someone constructed like
a fortress with lots of uh you know with
lots of security features but if
somebody does you know get past the
security features with a gun they still
they can't really
do anything aside from like lock
everyone down and sort of like hide in
the classroom until such time as a
person decides to leave and that's uh
my mind not a desirable situation
especially in light of the you know we
had just another school shooting in
Nashville as a member of this committee
uh aptly noted
and um
so this is a very timely hearing and
this is a vehicle certainly what we have
in there is good you should keep it but
it's a vehicle that could be used I'm
not necessarily
saying that it will be used but it could
be used for meaning meaningful school
safety legislation and and no I'm not
talking about doing something about side
doors on buildings um
next to that new school building I
mentioned most it does have a one side
door most of the other well most of the
side doors are actually like quite
armored so we would have been pretty
hard for a gunman to blow movement but
there is like
or like a couple of other side doors
that are not quite as art so I'm not
talking about eliminating side doors in
the school buildings I'm talking about
doing something about guns on school
campuses which uh is probably
um
which is anyway that's certainly
something that's within the community's
purview that would be a Germaine
Amendment whether or not you want to
take it up well that's up to you but
certainly I mean certainly what's before
you that's an excellent bill so you
certainly should at least pass that at a
minimum so I hope that's uh that's my
position that's my position Bill
normally
you know normally if if this has just
been introduced as is um I probably
wouldn't be sitting here today because
this wouldn't have attracted my
attention as much as it would but the
original bill and I understand you know
why the Senate education committee the
Senate did what it did but I think
probably we should do in the house we
should do even more than what this bill
does so that's uh that's why I support
this and I certainly hope you might
consider you might want to consider some
amendments to it to make it even
stronger and of course I'd be happy to
take any questions if anybody wants to
ask anything thank you very much
representative uh representative
cordelli thank you uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative what
you're talking about
um well it doesn't
apply directly to the legislation we're
looking at
um excuse me but are you bringing
forward any amendment that you've talked
about several things um that could be
added to this but you're not bringing
forward any Amendment at this point you
know correct I'm not a member of this
committee I'm not a member of the
criminal justice committee so it's
somewhat you know somewhat outside of uh
outside of my purview I'm more
suggesting this is something that could
have been done and you can also probably
revert back to the original bill which I
think
um
allow much more extensive communication
between a wider range of law enforcement
officers and uh
and the school districts for a wider
range of threats you know this is pretty
much if I read it narrowly focused on
disciplinary action against a student
who's either uh incarcerated and or
being
investigated by the police for violent
crime and so they can be disciplined by
the school even I suppose actually
something I'm on Judiciary so we hear a
lot about burden of proof the burden of
proof for suspending is sooner from
school is lower than that for criminal
conviction so even if someone hasn't
been proven guilty Beyond a reasonable
doubt there's still you know
preponderance of the evidence that that
students should not be in school so that
could be a useful information in some
cases so
further yes follow-up thank you
um
but you can follow up on those comments
um the proposed legislation refers to
169 B2 Roman 14 and I think that pretty
well covers an existing statute that
we're talking about serious threats to
school safety
and it outlines what those threats would
be that would
require
this communication between law
enforcement and the school are you
suggesting that there are other
threats that should be included in this
I'm not sure where you're going with
your testimony actually
well actually what they haven't 14 it
doesn't actually include
assault or murder for example what
happened
in Nashville and that was in another
state of private school so everything's
um but like uh for example what uh the
person in Nashville did that the only
thing really that's covered there is
criminal mischief because he she he
destroyed the side door of the of the
school it doesn't really cover actually
carrying a firearm on campus or
threatening people so that's actually I
mean
that certainly uh I mean that's those
are certainly that's certainly like a
very useful definition of the bill you
know but yeah I'm not I don't have any
specific amendments here I'm just
suggesting the possibility in case
people are feeling energetic they could
uh add to the spell
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um
you're talking about limits to law
enforcement and not across the state and
whatever and I don't know whether the
bill the bill as it showed up to us I
don't know what amendments and whatever
but as it showed up to us it just says
any law enforcement officer and so am I
missing the
narrowing that you're talking about
well that's a
law enforcement so it's a little bit
ambiguous in my mind whether that covers
uh
whatever Vermont law enforcement or
Massachusetts or making law enforcement
or even federal law enforcement if they
got involved somehow it probably
um so I think I'm not prepared to answer
that question there may be others here
in the room who might feel more
confident but I
um
I think it's I think as I read it it
would you you could probably you
probably run into some difficulty if you
had to work with those other law
enforcement agencies although I'm sure
any responsible School District would
would want to
know what's going on in another state or
at a federal level if it involved one of
questions from the committee represent
Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I just wanted to go
into the testimony a little bit to make
sure I can clarify
um because he testified that if a person
were if a person a member of the public
were to
carry a gun
circumventing school
um security measures and get into a
school that there's really nothing that
can be done under current law
but would you agree that if a person's
circumvented school security measures
just some random number of the public
would they not be trespassing they have
no right to be there right
um I don't know but the I know the
school districts are very cautious
with the firearms on campus because uh
because of the Second Amendment Lobby
has my mind
um you know somewhat I guess I would
play some big emphasis on the issue
there's a lot of concerns so I mean
probably there's probably something
you know there's probably something you
could charge them with but uh you're
merely having the gun without permission
there may be a case of someone's not
really trespassing per se they're
invited in but they weren't invited in
you know with the fire they bring the
firearm on campus so they can
because they were jumping off the topic
and we're way off this bill this bill is
very specific in terms of sharing
information between one agency and the
school district yeah thank you you're
right yes I agree before we got to
remain and uh also inform folks that I'm
meeting tomorrow with the uh billing uh
Public School infrastructure that
involves Homeland Security and Eddie
Edwards from Department of Safety uh
Deputy
um these are the type of things that
we're discussing over there and trying
to ensure that we have safety and
dealing with access dealing with
Communications uh within our our
buildings so
um I think what we all do is stick this
one right where it is the sharing of
information so that actually you know
the school district is familiar with it
and
um so if there's not any more questions
for our representative Horrigan is there
Department of Safety or or
okay if you like to fill out a pink card
foreign
that's confusing for many people so
so my name is Arana Hasbrouck and I was
actually a principal for Tim's children
when um they were when they were in high
school I'm currently a superintendent
and I approached him because of an
incident that had happened this fall
last spring in this fall
um we had a serious safety threat in our
school
involving potential of a weapon serious
safety threat in our school
when we went through the processes we
had our local police department
fortunately in this District I have a
police department but I do have three
districts and two of them do not they've
received coverage by the state police
because of the seriousness of this event
the state police were called in to also
assist us
when it came time to do a discipline
hearing with my board we were unable to
get follow-up information from the
police department because their attorney
believed that it was in violation of
current legislation
that was really frustrating because we
want to do the best by the student as an
individual but also as a broader scope
of the school district as a whole
because the safety of all of our
students is of utmost importance and
um
Lieutenant Cody was very very supportive
he shared what he could share but we
said we need to fix this if there are
situations that we need to know about
involving a school in a school matter we
need to know the outcome of it because
the only information we had was what the
parents wanted to share which was next
to nothing because they're looking to
advocate for their child
and we were told that what was being
shared was not accurate so I said
something has to happen if I'm to
function and Lead my boards and give the
best information for the safety of all
of our students we need accurate
information so I partnered with on the
attorney that had represented the school
district at that time wanted to be sure
that we got complete support spoke with
the commissioner of education and he
said to be sure and speak with attorney
Fenton which I had done we also did a
wraparound and reached out to the
Department of Safety with attorney I'm
not going to get it right my digliani as
well as Department of Health and Human
Services
um attorney Martinson
someone from there had come to also
speak when we went before the senate i
the Senate education committee and they
had concerns that we were looking for an
overreach to know all information
pertaining pertaining to a student
involved with the law enforcement and
that is not it at all we are just
concerned with matters that pertain to
school and school safety so that is why
this the second version came forward and
it is our belief that it does pertain to
all law enforcement because there are
some FBI involvement in our case as well
and we also our district that is right
around the Connecticut River on the
border and we have Vermont students that
attend our schools so reaching out with
many attorneys eyes this is what we
believed would get the intent that we
needed to bottom line get pertinent
information in our decision making
whether students can and can't be in
school and what the direct impact would
be on student safety
thank you very much are there questions
gives us certainly some background
information on it very good
not see any thank you very much
we do have someone from law enforcement
here as well
Sergeant are you have anything for us
thank you welcome do you have a pink
sort of like a ticket
[Laughter]
staff sergeant uh Ladd from troop F uh
the assistant troop Commander up in Twin
Mountain
um
as superintendent cataract said that we
were involved very heavily with this
incident in Northumberland
um and it actually became quite
frustrating with everything that's going
on in the world today especially in the
United States uh with school violence
one of the one of the big takeaways is
communication
and we see it so often in the news
follow days following these incidents
where there's little tidbits of
information
that people knew about but it wasn't
communicated or shared and when we try
to communicate with the school
we were informed uh by our attorney at
the department of safety uh that we
couldn't based on current legislation
and that was that was her interpretation
of that so we were very limited in what
we could share with the school
pertaining to our investigation
um so
in support of this this bill this will
allow us to communicate with these
schools reference uh threats of violence
that
um jeopardize school safety uh or
anything that jeopardizes school safety
and uh it's it's so very important
um in this incidence in particular uh
the follow-up to this uh a child tried
to get enrolled in a different School
the following year
that school contacted us for the police
reports
in doing their due diligence to make
sure that it's a safe environment for
their school and it's safe to have that
child come to their school we also
couldn't share those reports with that
that school district trying to take this
child on so I think
I'm hopeful that with this with this
legislation that those changes can be
made and we can share uh Communication
in these incidences are so very
important
thank you very much representative Myler
thank you Sergeant for being here and
sharing your story here the question I
guess I have is that how is the
information communicated for example
it's it's one thing
for the super for the SAU office to
contact you if they've got a student
coming in
uh would you would this law permit you
if you had a student who had been acting
out or had an incident or you had a
record
to initiate contact with the school
prior
to the school contacting you or is it
only the school district contacting you
and then you giving the information
I would say based on the way it's
a serious threat to school safety uh to
the reporting school officials for use
in disciplinary proceedings
um that that extra language that is
particularly for disciplinary
proceedings
the first paragraph of that that law I
would
um
I would say that we should be able to
share that
um but the way that it's written
my interpretation solely my
interpretation
is that it's for use in disciplinary
proceedings
conducted in accordance with 193.13 1B
and two so with that language your
interpretation would be that
the school district could be the one
that would contact you if they had a
question not the other way around if you
just want to alert them correct so now
um I would say in in general practice if
there was a if there was a school safety
threat we would we could be very vague
about what the information that we gave
to the school where we would do things
away from the school that they don't
necessarily need to know about until
they ask us yeah thank you
yes represent Lancaster and
representative Damon thank you
thank you for answering my question uh
following on with what you said since it
says in disciplinary proceedings and a
superintendent calling you to say is
this kid okay for us to take into our
school a new Superintendent at a new
school that's not a disciplinary
proceeding right so
in your interpretation would you then
not be able to say anything we
my interpretation would be yes because
that's not disciplinary
um so yes you are correct in that thank
you you're welcome representative Damon
thank you and thank you for being here I
think this is a version of the same
question and maybe we want to hear from
uh Diana Fenton as well
I'm questioning whether this allows law
enforcement to be proactive with the
schools
about a
something someone you perceive as a risk
to the schools it sounds to me like it
doesn't is that what you just indicated
that would this particular legislation
the way it's written I would I would
Sergeant I I also have a question along
the same line when we're talking about a
disciplinary proceeding then I go to the
statute and I say okay what is a serious
threat to school safety
and it specifies very specific areas
that you know it deals with Controlled
Substances weapons bodily injury
Etc uh so are we now walking and taking
this part of Statute and trying to apply
it to a disciplinary hearing that maybe
on some other topic
that's not specified under what a
do you do you have that statute I do
yeah I'm reading the the definition of
serious threat yeah yeah I'm reading
that right now for those that are here
and can you repeat your question one
more time please well the the question
is does it when we're talking in this
bill records relating to any report of a
serious threat to school safety
then we're going down on on line 13
we're talking about of two officials for
use in disciplinary proceedings
um so are
is a disciplinary proceeding can be held
for events which go beyond what is here
under the the serious threats to school
safety but you're only going to release
that information that's based upon not
I'm reading it based upon this section
of Roman 14 within this statutory area a
serious threat so it's somewhere along
the way you're gonna have to make the
decision is this related to this if it's
not related to that we're not going to
release the information I would agree
with you in that interpretation is is if
it fits based on the the verbiage if
it's a serious threat to school safety
whatever falls under as you said Roman
numeral uh 14.
where it defines serious threat to
school safety if it's not defined under
that I would say yes we would not be
able to release that thank you that's
what I'm trying to get at representative
cordelli thank you
um
uh we've heard some testimony about the
original language of the bill and I
would just point out that we're talking
in this what we have in front of us is
related for use in a disciplinary
hearing
whereas the original Bill language was a
little bit different in that it said for
the purposes of allowing a School
employee to take disciplinary action
so it wouldn't be directly related to a
discipline area hearing that was in
process or scheduled or something like
that but it would allow for I think more
communication
proactively which was another issue that
was brought up would you agree in that
that it would be more proactive
communication possibly I would agree
with you on that yes certainly think so
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I I think we've
gotten off a little bit on because I
have a little bit of a different reading
and I think a couple very brief
questions will steer Us in direction
that I think will help clarify some of
this stuff
would you agree that it would be General
inappropriate for police to just
casually share this information with
school officials I would yes okay
knowing that
would you agree that the only real way
for a school to mitigate a threat a real
threat would be along the lines of
disciplinary proceedings
I would agree therefore
anytime you're going to share this
information in a reasonable circumstance
with school officials would it not
therefore be for use any disciplinary
proceeding yes
thank you
my concern is that yes I agree with what
that conversation but you're going to
release information if it's paralleled
by the definition that we have in 14. so
if the disciplinary hearing is regarding
another event that's not supported by
that you're not going to release the
information I would agree and it falls
again back to the serious threat to
school safety if there is a serious
threat to school safety I think the
purpose
or at least the the design purpose is to
be able to communicate with the schools
to make them aware that there is a
threat in their school Community that's
the intent that's the Insight I get that
represent Tanner
thank you for taking my question in I'm
not sure you're the person to answer
this but when we talk about school in
this and refer to schools in this bill
obviously we were talking about a public
school situation
um and you know the recent shooting was
in a private school
um
would this apply uh to for example
public charter schools uh non-public
schools
if it isn't mentioned in the in the bill
should it be mentioned in the bill uh if
we want that
uh and have have in the past have you
so yeah I'm probably not the person to
answer that question but I can tell you
the what I was speaking of earlier in my
testimony it was actually a charter
school a private charter school that was
looking to admit the child and I was
still unable to share that information
with them
what are the questions
thank you very much Sergeant thank you
you have one other comment from the
superintendent
thank you for allowing me to clarify but
the intent behind this is not we do have
that reciprocity if there's a if there's
a safety concern we can call the police
department they respond if they say you
need to watch this today they can
respond to us this is about the actual
release of the records in the follow-up
that happened it's not about our lack of
communication when there are safety
threats I believe that that is strong
this is about the actual records that
happened as a result we had this event
there were proceedings there were police
proceedings there are police
consequences we were unable to know what
they were when we went to do an
expulsion hearing children when they're
expelled have to be out of school for
they can't come back to our school for
one year unless they meet the
specifications that were required
they go to seek to seek to go to a
charter school which and that's the
belief is this is just schools in
general that police can share
information with schools whether it's
public charter Christian private any any
school because
unfortunately we've all seen there
aren't boundary lines drawn out for us
and we just need to know that
information when we make our decisions
because a parent would feel that this
wasn't that big of a deal the school's
making this a much larger deal than it
is and we can only go off of the
information that the police are able to
as you said casually share with us but
that's not the specificity of yes this
child received this they have Juvenile
Detention they have this and this we
don't know that information which is
certainly relevant when we have an
expulsion hearing or we seek to do an
early re-entry or to extend a suspension
so that was the intent behind it it's
the school records we do have strong
relationships when there are safety we
all err on the side of caution giving
general information that is available to
us to the law
thank you represent luno thank you very
much Mr Mr chair and thanks again for
rejoining us this morning
um just to refresh my memory does the um
does the school district have any
obligations to educate the child uh
fought during and following a a an
expulsion
I can't quote it exactly we offer
services if the if the parents wanted
said they were homeschooled and they
wanted
um resources from us we can provide that
okay thank you welcome
that's a topic which we've gone into
very deeply as far as even other schools
being able to pick them up right I I
just can't remember
what I can say to clarify that if I if I
may we
um in the practice commonly throughout
the state and all the districts I've
been associated with would be offer ways
under free and appropriate public
education to offer as many ways for them
to come back to school as soon as
possible when it's deemed appropriate
for example we might request that they
they have um
a safety evaluation and we'll give an
option of through this person this
person this person or cross-reference it
that they do community service that they
meet with law enforcement that they go
through a diversion program so they have
opportunities to re-enter and just a
quick follow-up Mr chair on that yes so
so
um so districts
just to be clear districts do have
obligations to to provide uh free and
appropriate public education to students
who are
um in um in uh in County
um
um jails
having having been having broken the law
and been found guilty yes if they're in
a Detention Center we'll often do um
reciprocity with them through tutoring
or we will provide the materials to the
tutors that are in those institutions
okay okay thanks you're welcome okay yes
representative
thank you
I'm wondering if you would comment on
something that keeps
nudging in my head
does
the disciplinary proceedings of the
disciplinary process encompass
addressing the mental health of the
individual like I'm interpreting
disciplinary proceedings as something
punitive which may well be appropriate
but I'm concerned about that being the
only
approach being noted here
so certainly that's first and foremost
we always want to get to why this
happened to keep it from happening again
for this individual and for all
individuals so included in a re-entry
plan
it involves ongoing therapy or making
progress in mental health and what
services either we can provide to the
school or outside services that the
family demonstrates progress that the
family demonstrates educational progress
Etc
so those are always factors that are
taken it's educating the whole child
yes
so that sounds like that's your District
standard practice
but I don't understand the proposed
this particular legislation doesn't deal
with an expulsion it just deals with the
ability to share records
further further questions from the
committee thank you very much
you're welcome thank you
are there any other pink cards for this
bill 109
not seeing how close to hearing and the
next scheduled hearing I believe is at
10 45.
so if somebody has to take a short break
you may do so we have about eight
minutes
at the school style
and eventually brought one to the driver
if they did that now they'd be expelled
great point maybe expelled the family
I understood
okay folks we're going to go ahead uh
for the next hearing here
for the next number yeah I got the 155s
okay the bill that's that's on the
docket next here is SB 77 it's relative
to changes in school placement for
students and acting on behalf of Senator
abar Grant bossy is here to present this
bill
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I am Grant bossy Deputy Chief
of Staff of the New Hampshire Senate
here to introduce Senate Bill 77 on
behalf of Senator Kevin abart it's Prime
sponsor first I'd like to apologize for
Miss speaking during my introduction on
Transportation monitors uh sorry I got
you off track for a second there I'm
glad Diana was here to fix it
our education statutes are geared
towards the best interests of students
currently RSA 1933 gives each local
school board wide discretion in placing
students in other public schools public
academies or private schools if it
determines such placement is in the
student's best interest this is under
the Manifest education hardship
provision
this part of Statute used to apply only
to private non-religious schools but the
legislature in 2021 brought state law
into compliance with U.S Supreme Court
cases that found the states may not
exclude religious schools from programs
open to other private schools however in
drafting this change the bill
inadvertently left out references to
private schools in 133
3A so it's in the beginning of the
statute it's not down below in the
statute SB 77 would make the statute
consistent throughout clarifying that
local school boards may play students
wherever is in their best interests
again this is the local school boards
option placement in private schools is
already allowed under the law such
placement would remain at the discretion
of local school boards SB 77 would have
no anticipated impact on state or local
education spending it merely cleans up
193.3 to make the option of private
school placements consistent Senator
abart thanks you for your consideration
and urges your support for Senate Bill
thank you very much a grant
um obviously are you not taking any
questions I am minimally qualified to
answer questions on this bill so and
anything I can't answer I can get to
Senator ever
is there anything from the committee
no thank you probably probably not okay
um are there any other folks that want
to testify on this bill I only have that
um
very handy
go ahead all right thanks thank you very
much Diana for joining us again this
morning
um when uh with with the with the change
right here
um adding uh approved Private School uh
within the district or in another
District to this to this Clause does um
if it's an approved private school
that's that means approved by the local
school board and paid for by the 100
percent by the local school district
I'm not sure off the top of my head
because this is the this isn't um
this this is not a and I'll just sort of
for lack of better words this isn't an
ed Choice uh provision this is Manifest
educational hardship so this is in in in
in a school districts
constitutional obligation or a legal
obligation to provide a free and
appropriate public education so so no
cost should be borne by the family if if
through manifest educational hardship
it's the school board's position to
place the student in in accordance with
all that whole that whole chapter yes
educational hardship and best interests
the two are in the same 1933 yes right
right but that doesn't place a financial
obligation on the on the parents that is
correct all right thank you
further questions yes representative
Milo and thank you for taking my
question so if this is a as I recall
a school district placement
uh for the best interest of the students
and the parents were to happen to
disagree with that placement
under best interests and manifest
educational hardship
it's set out I think
more clearly in the administrative rules
as to what that process is and how much
the parents can weigh in
so it's a different standard for best
interest in manifest educational
hardship I speak with hesitation only
because the rules are not in front of me
but I know that that is taken into
account
so the child's not just placed at
another school there is Parental input
to that and we can go into more detail I
can look at those administrations thank
you very much
representative
thank you thanks for taking my question
I was in going back to that approved
private school that seemed like a phrase
as in state approved you know the state
has all of those
what makes an approved school and all
that kind of stuff is would that be
correct or that was that was my thought
as well when I look at that phrase I
think that was my hesitation with
representative Luna's question is
approved private school is a term that I
would apply to the department that it's
been approved by the department
thank you the local school district
might have a contract with that school
district but there there is another
section of law it's it's 194
23-b 58 page 585 in in the law book
it's it's under approval of high schools
yeah and the commissioner of the
Department of Education made through an
agreement with another state when such
data in New Hampshire are parties to an
interstate agreement allow New Hampshire
pupils to attend schools that meet the
standards established by one of the two
states and but the item one underneath
that talks about having to attend and
approve School are approved by the State
Board of educations complying with
provisions of 19423 uh so that that's a
it's another area of Statute which you
know addresses the the the approval
requirements
yeah yeah represent cascadden
um I have the exact same language
um section uh Roman numeral two under
manifest educational hardship section d
reads the exact same thing including
approved private school within the
district or to a
public
school or public Academy or an approved
private school in another District
that's already in statute yeah I'm on
page 507.
so what's different you're correct so if
you look at 1933 in its entirety you'll
see that language if you look at Roman
numeral one C because I hate when people
throw out legal citations so one C it's
at the bottom of page 506 or an approved
private school
so it's there yeah it's in other areas
yep it's in D yep
it's not and as we went through and made
these changes
um and I'm just trying to look at the if
you look at the annotations or the
Amendments on page 509 that gives you a
very brief summary of the legislative
changes that were made
you'll see that they um trying to find
the year that we made them but
in short
when we made those initial changes to
add in that that phrase approved private
school
um
we just didn't look as far as we should
have down to e okay
that's just missing language there but
that makes me suspicious now
as to why the school boards Association
and the administrators Association would
oppose this
and maybe Jared can speak to that after
I
I'm not here to speak for them not here
to speak from but the question I asked
of you earlier when we were
briefly back there
um we have a set of uh we have a bill SB
266 is coming before us cleaning up 8306
and when I was reviewing it last night
on page eight it talks about private
schools
and in this report
uh Ed 306 would be changed from private
schools to non-public schools so those
two terms non-public school and private
school are interchangeable my
understanding is that they're
interchangeable and we've certainly
within the department use them
interchangeably
I think the preferred term is non-public
that's what I've well I I get that your
these rules are basically these changes
are coming from the Department yes and
where we have private they're changing
it to read non-public and I'm sure we'll
be back next year with this same bill
changing our terminology well this
bill's dealing with private
so
whatever we do we better do it so we
don't have to come back and re-change it
I hope this is something that the
department is continuously working on
and we've been before this legislative
body with issues in credentialing so
it's something that we as a state agency
are always grappling with is just trying
to be consistent with their terminology
with our terminology and it is a
struggle
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
thank you
are there any other folks that have
pink cards or like to say something here
in regard to this bill if not I'll close
School administrators
we were invoked so I okay
that's okay you know
you everything you learn you learn in
kindergarten you must not have gone to
kindergarten
there was no public kindergarten in my
Jerry fruit with New Hampshire school
administrators Association thank you for
the opportunity to speak just a quick
follow-up on that comment about no
public kindergarten made the comment one
I had gone to a
one to eight School
it had taken me eight years to get out
and uh comment in the background was
well that's now a four grade school so
it took you twice as long to get out as
you should have so there's an indication
of what you're dealing with folks
and so I do uh I do just want to take a
quick moment and
um
reiterate what chairman Ladd has brought
up that this bill is not ready for prime
time once again we see an indication of
um more work for this committee a year
from now as the department pointed out
that they'll be coming back seeking a
different solution and so I would just
encourage this committee to set aside
this piece of legislation to work it
over make it right so that once again
next year we aren't having the same
conversation about the same issues and
let's just get it right one time
um
and that's all I'm going to say
represent cordelli thank you thank you
for uh jumping in
um is your concern in that this is not
ready for Prime Time
concerning the use of approved private
school language or is there something
else that you think is a troubling
relation to the uh Bank propeller
question it's a little bit of both uh
representative cordelli it is the
language of the private school it's also
the the notion of where public money is
going
um to support various institutions thank
you for that question
representative
to avoid coming back
if we took all of that section of Law
and every place where it says approved
private school which were adding this
into to make it consistent if we did
approved non-public school
and just added all of those in would
that be something that you could support
thank you for the question
representative leckis uh it would be
consistent with our resolutions as they
currently stand for us to oppose this
legislation in any fashion okay thank
so you're not anti
particularly the non-profit non-public
school private school you're just
I I'm getting the concern that you're
against the Manifest education process
where a superintendent could decide to
send a child that was not fitting in the
situation due to all the rationale in
manifest education to the Montessori
School
I believe what we currently have in
statute would allow that to happen if
that were a local agreement I couldn't
I'm not a lawyer
so I can't speak to that for certain but
I believe if that was the agreement that
was set up locally under current statute
that that could still happen
thank you further questioning
thank you very much thank you chairman
thank God coming thanks
any further pink cards on this one
not seeing outside
yeah
it just goes right to Alicia right there
and it just goes around the table up
that's my sister
you get push the red button
hi my name is Caden SAU 67 uh retiring
at the end of this year after 16 years
ago you may remember me uh I was here
testifying on this bill when you changed
manifest educational hardship and best
interest
so I want to take you a little bit on
the history lesson
um
best interest in manifest educational
hardship used to be a very good tool for
superintendents to deal with individual
issues in their school system there were
two separate processes best interest was
basically a superintendent process that
you could deal with the student who was
having difficulty in school talk to
another superintendent you know perhaps
there's a bullying situation perhaps it
was a bad breakup or something where one
of your students just really couldn't
continue in in your school needed a
fresh start someplace else worked out
with the other superintendent oftentimes
it was a quid pro quo no tuition changed
hands and so forth
and then manifest hardship was a
slightly different process where uh that
involved your school boards having to uh
to make a decision about that when you
rewrote the best interest in manifest uh
hardship rules uh the last time you
rewrote them you almost put them in
lockstep with each other you almost put
them as like the best interest decision
and then it gets immediately appealed to
the school board in manifest hardship
I've used them a number of times over my
career most the biggest time I use them
with Dunbarton joined
um Bo and the students were changing
high schools from Goffstown High School
to Beau and there was about seven or
eight students who came before us and
said no there's a real reason why we
should stay in Goffstown high school and
we worked that out with the boards now
this process seems to be moved a little
bit more towards school choice
and I know that that's the bent of of
this legislature that we do on open
choice and we do want to open ways
prepare parents to have their children
go to different places and I understand
that but I'm concerned that we're moving
you know bit by bit into this is a
vehicle of school choice instead of what
it was originally designed to be is for
superintendents to manage
students between Public School Systems
all in there
thank you very much other questions
I reference Senate
I superintendent Cascade you can call me
Dean Heidi
we know each other from way back when in
the Hanover area tight lunch
um
so
proving manifests educational hardship
though has a lot of criteria so it's not
really as wide open you know as as
regular school choices and does it not
matter that you have to go through a lot
of Loops to get to a place where you
would be able to do that
and it should be I mean it shouldn't be
uh I just don't like my school or you
know I I don't like my friends that are
there it should be a severe case of when
it was where a kid really is struggling
to be in school and maybe needs a
different venue I just understand why we
have to open that up to a private school
I mean what why can't you just leave it
the way it's been a public school to
public school because that's taxpayer
money going from
uh one place to another okay follow up
yes all right so is there opportunity
now to be kind of a frivolous excuse
rather could you speak in your mic I've
the idea of changing school just because
you don't want to be in one school
that's that doesn't meet the educational
hardship is there a way to meet that
requirement for a kind of a frivolous
excuse at this point well
you can always bring the case I mean you
can always bring the case to the
superintendent and superintendent will
look at it I I would tend to say uh no
to many cases that come to me because I
don't think they rise to the level of a
real manifest educational hardship and I
say no and and we move that on what's
the appeal of this doesn't it come to
the state school board so that's the
other thing even the local school board
who says okay we've gone through our
hearing we've made our decision then it
thank you thank you you asked
um what's the point of private school
but if I would ask you if there was a
child who say was Autistic or whatever
and couldn't deal with the size of your
school or the other local schools nearby
and there was a small private school
with few students who was more that was
what the child needed would you have
turned would you turn them down just
because it was a private school
we wouldn't have that discussion in that
realm if it was a student with autism or
any other student with a disability they
would go through the special ed process
and we have the right to place any of
those students in a private educational
setting that that's approved by the
state so special ed students do have a
process that they can go through to be
placed in I would say any private school
um you know so recently we had a case
come through where where a student
wanted to be placed in a basically a
private school no no special ed really
component to it and we were like no
you know you can't say that your
specialty needs are going to be met
better in a private school
because they don't have any special ed
programs and they don't have something
that they can meet their needs so in
your case you do already have a um a
mechanism to do that into the special
art process so follow up if
um
if the student wasn't coded say they
weren't autistic but they still couldn't
do
sorry no worries
couldn't do anything still couldn't deal
even if they weren't coded as special
needs that they needed a small
environment maybe they were behavior
problems with all or whatever I don't
know
you would say well sorry you're not
coded you don't get to go to the smaller
School let's just back up a little bit
first of all I would mean with that
parents and develop a program within my
own school to meet their needs I mean I
and I think that's the part that you
don't understand is that schools all the
time are dealing with kids who have
difficulty in school creating programs
creating schools within schools creating
uh special things for students and you
know at least in my experience and
you've got to remember Bo has resources
boa's resources we can do things that
other schools can't
and so but what I oftentimes see in the
Manifest educational hardship uh cases
that I've dealt with is we've gone
through that we've made that decision
and really what the parents looking for
is a private school placement and if
they want a private school placement New
Hampshire law is very clear they can
have one but they have to pay for it
thank you I think we're way off topic
here uh on what this bill is about we're
talking about rulemaking for for the
Manifest education our best interest in
manifest education portion of Statute
here and when we're talking about those
sections all those parts are already in
place with this verbiage
uh we're just talking simply the rule
making Authority given by way of that
section e at the base of all the
Manifest education it doesn't change the
the requirements for best interest which
is based on certain needs of the student
which can be made locally or the
pervasive severe issues associated with
group manifest education hardship so
let's keep it to the the topic the rule
making process yes so thank you Mr chair
actually just a a comment first on what
your remarks here I've been looking at
the statute as as you are as well and
and you know I know we work together in
developing this so we work with the
school boards and the School Board
Association basically I'm doing this but
it's it's not an easy statute to read by
any by any means
um and and
e is um is uh also not easy to read but
I think what this is doing what what 77
is doing is actually not with respect to
department rules but with respect to the
school board shall establish a policy
consistent with the state board's rules
and then it it reads on so it it it
doesn't necessarily say that the school
board I mean it's it it says the school
board's got to establish a policy with
respect to uh um appropriate action
including assignment to another public
school or public Academy within the
district or public school public Academy
outside of the district and I think that
might be falling back on what Dr
cascadden was um was was referring to
when the superintendent is making a
recommendation because it talks about
that too with the recommendation of the
superintendent
I think this is different than
the um
I know we're sort of this is sort of
exact session talk yeah but but I just
sort of wanted to put it out there that
it's not about I don't think it's about
rules I think it's about policy and and
I guess I'd love to maybe get get uh ask
Dr cascadden for some thoughts on what
the intent of the what that lot not the
intentional about what that part of the
law is really really getting at
so we would have to write a policy that
says that we would allow a student to
attend a private school as part of a
manifest educational
oh the existing laws say your question
again I'm sorry well so the existing law
says that all
um
each School Board shall establish a
policy consistent with the state board's
rules which shall allow a school board
with the recommendation of the
superintendent so now you're with within
the authority of the superintendent
to take appropriate action including
assignment to another public school or
public Academy within the district or to
a public school or to a public Academy
in another district and and to that it
sounds to me that that's within a
superintendent's Authority and in
working with other superintendents and
the school board is establishing a
policy
I'd have to go back and read I don't
have the full uh one in front of me but
if going from memory the school board
has to approve the decision right right
in the day back when I was a younger
superintendent school board didn't have
to approve the decision the
superintendent could make that uh
decision and it would go and you could
work with he or she could work with
other superintendents and make that
happen the last time you revised this
the board had has to approve that
decision on the superintendent's
recommendation and what you're looking
at now is is opening that up Beyond you
know publicly funded schools to private
schools and I think that's outside the
scope of what this rule was intended to
be
is that outside of the scope of the
school board
um I mean how how would they be able to
set a policy involving private schools
well that's that I think that's the
point we're talking about right so I'm
sitting in front of my school board who
collects taxes from Beau New Hampshire
and saying we're going to send those to
a private school we're not going to send
those to another school in New Hampshire
we're going to send it to a private
school is there any quid pro quo we're
going to be able to have with that
private school I just don't see it being
consistent with how this statue was
originally what it was originally meant
to do
I think and that's why I brought it to
school we're getting way off track here
uh I believe uh uh because to get into
this discussion you're going to have to
go literally through this entire process
yes when I was in the administrative
business and just like Bruce Labs was if
I want to talk to somebody down
employment man that those changes
occurred back and forth back and forth
all the time and they worked it was an
informal process however that's not what
we're what we are in this world today uh
thing things are really and it's a
different ball game uh so I to for us to
start going in and looking through this
whole thing again uh I'm not prepared to
I'm sorry if I distracted you
representative cascaden
superintana cascadden thank you former
which one's my turn
um I see he is a different entity I
think I'd asked Diana Fenton a question
and it looked like it was just language
that was missing but this as uh
represented my um Uno pointed out this
is pertaining to the school district
establishing a policy which they can't
as you alluded to can't make a policy
that says we're gonna also provide for a
private school education
whereas the other parts that include the
non-public or the pro the private entity
the law gives a school district latitude
to be able to exercise that right if the
only option is the Montessori School
within the district it's a good fit with
a kid
then that school board with that
superintendent would have that
discussion but I think the policy making
is what's
the way business is done but I think it
but I think it it provides latitude to
do that
but when you're making a policy you're
not going to have a public policy that
alludes to you're going to play for
private education that's how I interpret
the two so that's why I'm questioning
why there's even a need of this
um
dispel
because it clearly states that if
there's a private school and that's the
best solution
then that can happen
but I from a policy perspective I don't
think you can write a policy that says
you're going to send your
public money to private at this stage of
the game I that's why I'm looking at it
yeah
further discussion or not discussion
because we're not an exact session uh
questions
of
yes
so so thank you Mr chair and and thank
you uh superintendent cascad
um does um does the the district where
your superintendent currently have such
a policy
you're required to have a best interest
uh and a manifestation manifest
educational hardship last time we
rewrote it was the last time we wrote
the rules so we were in compliance with
it okay and to follow up on that
um and and if the school board so it was
so inclined
um uh based on the the law here the the
law in the book not the not the bill
um uh the the
um that policy would have to include
assignment to another public school or
public Academy within the district or to
a public school or public Academy in
another District but if the board were
so inclined
um uh could they could they include
um uh assignment to a non-public school
if they had moved such non-public school
and
I I believe so I mean I'm dealing with
Goshen Leinster right now they have
become basically a uh you know a
district of choice and school boards can
do pretty much what they want to do they
can violate their own policies and right
and so forth I I think you already have
it in there what my fear is is when you
put this in then a citizen saying well I
want to send my kid to a nice little
private school I'm going to come and I'm
going to and it's just that's not what
this was designed to be it was not
designed to be let's let's pick and
choose a school where we need to go is
designed to give School administrators a
chance to really deal with some issues
and so I feel I know I'm getting off
topic and I'm sorry that I'm distracting
you but I feel it's pushing a larger
agenda instead of dealing with a
legitimate problem thank you
further questions
any further pink cards on this bill
not CNN I'm going to close the hearing
.
foreign
Thirty we we open up sve 155 at 11 30 so
that skips us about eight minutes here
okay
thank you
which one is that 155 well let's put it
practice
is
concept
thank you
okay we're going to go ahead with this
hearing we have 10 cards for people who
want to testify in The Sewing and
eliminate limit the time to speak other
than the presenter to three minutes a
person
uh so people have uh written testimony
could you please try to summarize where
you are on that
um so with that I'd like to welcome uh
for SBE 155 this is relative to the
adoption of school administrative unit
budgets uh Grant bossy thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee uh I
remain Grant bossy uh from the New
Hampshire Senate introducing Senate Bill
155 on behalf of its prime sponsor
Senator Kevin avert I will not need more
than three minutes over the past 20
years spending on education has grown
dramatically even as the number of
students in New Hampshire schools has
fallen administrative costs have gone up
faster than almost any other piece of
local school budgets Senator abar
believes that local voters should have
more direct control over the cost of
school administration SB 155 would
require the annual SAU budget be a
separate Warren article from the
school's operating budget this is in
line with New Hampshire's tradition of
direct democracy where voters make
independent decisions on on various
budget proposals I just voted on my
School District budget on Tuesday in
town sharing an SAU voters would
consider warrant articles on each Town's
piece of that SAU bud
given administrative budgets their own
place on the town ballot would increase
transparency and accountability Senator
thanks you for your consideration and
ask for your support of Senate bill 155.
thank you all right and once again if
you have any questions I can get them to
center of our dancer right thank you
and we'll hold our quick do you have a
question for uh Mr bossy I have a
question for him to pass on to the
senator okay and my question is if that
is the purpose of this and you're
talking about local control
um and uh
why shall it not be amended or changed
in any way prior to the vote at a town
meeting when
um that's kind of what's supposed to
happen at a town meeting is the town
weighs in on such things and makes such
changes as a group that they
see is more advantageous so that's my
question all right is there a particular
line in the bill that I could reference
yeah that would be well it's it's 12
through 15 and particular line 14.
page two I'm sorry yes
I lost Senator Everton have him get an
answer back to the committee thank you
thank you
thank you very much
I'd like to welcome representative
sellers
thank you Mr chair good morning
committee
representative sellers Grafton 18.
I also uh was a sponsor on the the same
bill you actually heard earlier in the
year it was uh I believe it was House
Bill 563 and in a case we're looking at
155 this is almost identical to that but
what I want to show is a couple things
under my belt here I have almost seven
years of budgeting experience three of
those years have been with the school so
I'm aware of how budgets work with the
school I'm also our school district
actually uses an sb2 type format so I
understand how that works as well
uh I did send you all an email last
night very short so you don't have to
read a you know more than four or five
lines and I hope you had a chance to
look at that but what I want to say on
this is it just gives more transparency
to the voters that's one of what it does
by separating it into a separate warrant
article
looking at a budget when the people
actually come out to the deliberative
session in my case
they are handed a more of a summary
budget they're not handed a detailed
1600 line item budget
and other 1600 line items it does just
say Administration it doesn't show each
individual person's salary or how much
the SAU office cost Etc but there is you
can go to the de
doe website and you can get that
information but most people don't really
know how to do that and how to get that
information so by putting this into a
separate warrant article would be very
helpful and be very clear to the people
saying hey uh administrative costs is
this uh school cost is this so now they
can see here you have administrative
cost goes up 28 percent they could say
whoa we don't maybe want to vote for
that and they have a separate warrant
article and they have what they call as
I would call it as a default budget
default budget is always last year's
budget plus or minus some
you know changes at that point but
technically it's last year's budget so
there will never be less than last
year's budget all right at that point so
now they can actually decide do I want
to spend that extra 28 on just the SAU
portion or do I you know I'll do not and
then the school budget is the same idea
that uses a proposed budget and also a
default budget as well which the voters
get the vote on it's pretty
straightforward pretty simple
um I'm just trying to think what else I
can say on this the
I think overall it's the transparency
and I think last time when you guys were
talking through this and actually
through your notes on in the calendar it
was stated that there is a process that
the school board can actually put this
as a separate warrant article which is
true
but this is actually
let's say it's taken this out of the
school board's hand or out of the budget
committee's hands and actually putting
it as a warrant article so it's given
the voters a better say how their money
is being spent so you know having that
option of the school board saying well
maybe we will maybe we won't or maybe we
have a favorable School Board maybe you
don't have a favorable school board so
one year you'll have it on there the
next year you won't and I think that can
be very confusing to voters so I think
that's all I got on this any questions
thank you very much representative
cordello you have your hand up thank you
uh thank you for being here again
um I'm just curious you mentioned um the
administrative costs are found on the
doe website
um I'm not sure where that is but
um are you talking about administrative
costs for the individual School
or for these uh SAU I'm not sure what
you refer to when you're talking about
administrative costs because there are
administrative cost specific
um to the school as well as business
operations let's say for the SAU okay so
I I think another uh speaker will
actually help you out on that question
as well but my understanding I believe
it's uh a12d that you can look at on the
oh maybe you'll know the answer to my
earlier question
um
and especially since you're an sb2 town
which we are now
um we can amend that
in deliberative session and I'm
wondering why it's being taken out of
uh town meeting because I know when we
had town meeting there were times when
the school board asked for a and we were
not willing to give them a but we were
willing to give them more than the
default budget and we came to a
compromise that everybody agreed on and
I'm wondering why that you've taken that
ability out so it's now either up or
down which you know it seems like it
would be better for the taxpayers to be
able to say we're not willing to give 28
but we're willing to give 14 percent
and everybody votes on that and it's
positive as opposed to 28 percent no so
I can't answer that question for you
and Mike in our case we are in sb2 town
all right or an sb2 School Board a
school
so you have a derivative session at that
deliver session you can adjust that
value I know we do that now so you're
right you can do that but when you're
looking at a budget at the sb2 they they
will go in and say I want to adjust the
budget by let's say a hundred thousand
dollars all right what will happen is
the budget committee or the school board
will then go back into the budget after
the fact Ian decide which line items to
take that hundred thousand out of so
here it's just breaking it up into two
pieces
so you'd have either a say on the SAU
portion or you have a say on just the
school portion that's all well you do
have a way of mending it I got that if
your SP2 that's not changed in this but
in line the same line I was talking
about earlier line 14 on page two where
it says
and I where it says
um at your school board meeting that's
people who have school board meetings
still and not SP2 it shall not be
amended or changed in any way prior to
the vote and that's you're taking that
ability to make a compromise away from
the taxpayers and I'm wondering well I
can understand if it's a co-op
and you have all these different towns
you don't want them doing that but they
it applies to single towns as well and
I'm wondering why you're taking that
ability for a single town to come to a
compromise which I know our town when we
were school when we were
um before sb2 we did that numerous times
I hear what you're saying and I I see I
just read what you uh were talking about
and
I'm going to have to leave that part of
that question up to another speaker that
actually
in depth went through this and wrote
this at this point Thank you very much
and hopefully that speaker will identify
themselves yeah we're almost there okay
thank you yeah I hope that's so uh
because 566 and this is a replicate of
that
went down 19-1 in this committee yeah
563 I think it was yes 563 right yeah
yeah and you're and you're right and I
was disappointed because I I thought it
would give more clarity and and I think
the reason that I saw in the calendar
was because
um
there was a way that the school board
could already put that on as a separate
warrant out of but that was optional and
if the school would wanted to do that
okay thank you uh are there any other
questions because we have another eight
to follow or nine if I can do my modern
math correctly here thank you very much
thank you uh Winfrey
thank you chairman lad and we have
passed out your okay paperwork yeah so
I'll just I'll be brief I know it's
three minutes
um
members of the education committee uh I
come before you to oppose uh Senate Bill
um Senate Bill 1556 to force school
districts to develop and present a
separate Warren article
um
for the budget of the school
administrative unit I represent Kia
Sarge in the towns of Bradford Newberry
New London Springfield Saturn Warner and
Wilmot and we have chosen to include the
seu budget as part of our district
budgets and the Inception of the school
district and dsau
voters have always been informed about
the costs of the SAU they are fully
aware and clear about the total expenses
that we propose and they actively
execute their right to provide input
feedback and make modifications during
the deliberative session
both working with the school board and
the municipal budget committee
districts are free to create as was
mentioned earlier warrant articles that
are separate for any of the budget items
they wish to bring before the
legislative body to vote on
those districts and seus are free to
continue that practice with or without
the passage of Senate bill 155.
for districts like mine that have chosen
to include their seu expenses in the
overall budget
SB 155 does nothing but casts an
additional burden on the operations of
the district I do not see any
Improvement there
it does not help the current practice
there's also no increase in efficiency
there's no additional transparency for
the citizens of the district
on the contrary the bill solves the
problem it doesn't exist it forces
school board members and Municipal
budget committee members to develop
three budgets instead of one
and it does nothing to improve the
quality of Education in kiosarch in fact
it does have the potential to limit and
hamper the ability to for the district
or the SEO to hire appropriate and
skilled Personnel to lead the
organization if that happens through
retirement the relocation or taking
other positions in other districts and
we need to then replace those positions
after the budgets are passed so you
should be hopefully primarily concerned
about finding ways to effectively and
efficiently support education of our
children in New Hampshire and hopefully
not make it more cumbersome for our
public schools to serve the public I
urge you to vote against SB 155 as you
have done in the past with the House
Bill thank you very much are there
questions for the superintendent
yes represent dry thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
following up on what representative
lekas was asking when it's presented as
law in your budget is there an
opportunity for the voting the
deliberative body there to change any of
the numbers or is it just transparency
absolutely and they have in the past uh
we also have two budgets at the NBC the
municipal budget committee presents and
the school board present in deliberative
session
um changes can be made we had just
recently won uh disagreement between NBC
and school board over one administrative
position that was presented it was
debated and in fact the lower budget was
passed then uh in our district we are we
are SP2 to the extent that we have our
own Charter so we are that would require
us to develop the budget for the school
board and then the
um the SAU budget and the default budget
so that would I can only see it as
additional burden on the business office
as well as not really adding
transparency because it is already
transparent we have 1175 lines
open to the public every time everybody
can inspect it and my other concern
would be if we go down that route
um
you know what other segments do we pull
out
um or be forced to be pulled out is it
you know is it the grounds and
maintenance is it uh speech pathologist
is it um operating costs for books and
and papers so that today in my view it
doesn't add transparency because it's
already there
further questions representative or
Tanner thank you thank you for taking my
question so you have the budget with you
today that that stapled group is that
available at all meetings and and uh is
it available in the town report school
report that's given out to all taxpayers
and is it available to
budget committee people I mean where is
it where is it not available I guess is
there any is there any way that it's
kept from the public absolutely not
um any any member of the public in
District or from anywhere else can
request that information it's it's
posted on our website it's available
copies are available and in fact uh
people from the public do come to our uh
budget preparation meetings and can ask
and do ask many questions about specific
uh superintendent have you tried to
estimate what this would cost you as a
district in terms of additional
administrative costs
that's hard to estimate it would be uh
it would be an additional it would be
additional meeting time for NBC and
board it would be additional time for
the business office to separate that out
prepare that
um how to put a dollar figure with that
but it's it's again one of those
many things that you know we will do if
we are told to do that but it adds
administrative costs there's no doubt
about it thank you
further questions
not seen thank you very much thank you
for your time I'd like to invite uh
thank you Mr chairman
Jerry fruit with New Hampshire school
administrators Association I will be
brief because I know you're on a shore
at least just wanted to encourage the
members of this committee uh to take the
time to read the 23 pieces of written
testimony that have been submitted
online
uh I think there is some great
information uh contained in those in
those uh testimonials from a variety of
size school districts and towns and
members of communities that bring out
some very valid points
um I sit here listening to testimony and
wonder people criticize the
administrative costs and the expense in
school districts and then this body the
greater body and the one on the other
side
continue to add requirements and time
and responsibilities to local school
districts and then wonder why Personnel
costs increase and and local budgets get
exasperated by having to have additional
people
um
this particular bill called for fiscal
note I and forgive me if I've missed
that fiscal note but I haven't seen the
opportunity to to review that this is a
local decision
uh as superintendent fenneberg pointed
out
budgets are very transparent they're
open to the public they're detailed I
can remember as a superintendent
presenting to the budget committee a
budget Committee Member wanting to
remove a tuba from our budget that's how
granular budgets are presented in
communities they didn't like the fact
that we were getting a new tuba because
we could go get a secondhand tuba and it
would be
cheaper so I just point that out and in
small districts and I think about Hill
for for example uh superintendent
principal special education director and
sometimes food service coordinator Brian
Corcoran who does all those things on
any given day when his when his special
education director resigned with two
weeks before the school year he was a
superintendent he was a day-to-day
principal he was then the super the
special ed director and oh by the way
his cook was out on medical leave and so
he was serving peas and cucumbers so
those are the types of things that
happen in small districts it's very
difficult to discern what is an SAU cost
what is a building level cost and who
does what to pull those things apart and
then what happens in a district like
sau16 or SAU 48 who you'll hear from in
a little bit when one District says no
how does that impact the services to
that small District within the scope of
the SAU I don't need to say more you've
heard it before you're going to hear
some more
um but I would encourage you that this
bill is uh inexperiod to legislate and
please read the testimony that was
submitted so I don't have to come back
and read to you thank you got six more
seconds done
thank you thank you very much
and we also passed out the testimony
both ways
thank you chairman Ladd and honorable
members of the committee um you have my
written testimony as the chairman just
indicated so my comments today will be
brief as the chairman said my name is
Daniel Rosner I'm the business
administrator for SAU 48 which is
arguably the most complex SAU in the
state we have seven we have excuse me
nine independent school districts seven
follow traditional meeting two are sb2
um my point I'm also happened to be the
moderator of the town in which I reside
not a school district moderator but I am
the town moderator
um
my position is that the legislation
that's currently in place relevant to
the subject of SAU budgets is
satisfactory there's a base process
there's an alternative process and
that's enough
um
I believe a part of the history of this
proposal comes stems from a failed local
proposal and that doesn't necessarily in
my mind mean it should be translated to
a Statewide mandate
local control is a vast and important
part of New Hampshire history
I will say that multi-district saus are
particularly complex
and that Community especially in the
sau's I've been affiliated with our
Communications with our communities is
wide open we have for the development of
the SAU budget and Adoption of the SAU
budget we have multiple public hearings
that are duly noticed advertised in
local papers and open for input from the
public
prior to the adoption of our annual
budget the officials that are elected to
oversee our school districts and their
finances in SAU 48 we have 47 school
board members in total across the nine
independent school districts they are
all members of the SAU board that
approves this said budget
much like the state legislature voters
have a remedy for dissatisfaction when
or if it exists I can't imagine that
once you and the Senate work so hard to
approve a state budget if you would then
put it up back out to a local vote how
frustrating or time-consuming or
inefficient that would be
furthermore as a moderator as I've said
with the process that's called for in
this contemplated legislation I believe
the sanctity security and Clarity of
elections in New Hampshire uh what is a
nationwide model currently this
legislative legislation threatens to
impute that with the transference of
ballots and movement of ballots if you
have nine districts voting separately
and the ballots on this one article
would have to move around across the SAU
and then be counted in the final night
which is what this legislation calls for
it's untenable
that's the end of my testimony thank you
for your time very much are there
questions for Mr Rosner yes
representative drawing thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um appreciating that this is a mandate
because it says shall would it change
anything for you if it changed to a May
and was able to be done in smaller
districts that are less complicated
um
I think so it's an interesting thank you
for your question I'm not that I'm uh
qualified to interpret it but I will say
that I believe the current legislation
in RSA 194
provides the alternative process that
you speak what if it becomes a may it
becomes an alternative process that
could be adopted and I think that
already exists which renders the change
the change would render the proposed
legislation
even more unnecessary that I believe
uh could you explain to me what are the
districts in pemmy Baker sure we have
Romney well no we have nine independent
school districts okay and I can list
them off for you would you please sure
Camden yeah which operates a K-8 yeah
Ellsworth which is a tiny little
District doesn't operator school
tuitions it's students
to various districts within the SAU
holderness
Plymouth also a K-8 holderness to
Plymouth rumney Thornton Waterville
Valley and Wentworth they're all
independent school districts that
operate a K-8 school and we have the
penny Penny Baker Regional School
District which is our Cooperative High
School which has seven member towns
as you'll see in my written testimony
one of the member towns of our seven
Town Cooperative is Ashland
which is particularly complex because
the Ashland School District which is a
K-8 is a member of sau2 Interlakes
but the town of Ashland is a member of
the pemi baker Regional School District
which is Plymouth Regional High School
which is part of SAU 48.
so this notion of the it gets it gets
wild
it makes the multi-district issue for
single first multi-district SAU is
particularly complex as this is
contemplated well that's huge Waterville
to Ashland all the way over to Wentworth
we're the largest so we have the most
independent school districts of NES even
the state we're also the largest
geographical area I mean on a day when I
go from the Largo Valley Elementary
School to Wentworth I'm driving 45 miles
one way yeah and and that's fine
um but there are so many different ways
in which
as they use are con are constructed you
know whether it be my first assignment
as a ba was was uh with a Mr sellers
Community as as newfounds ba which was a
seven Town single Cooperative District
which is somewhat equivalent to our high
school in terms of political structure
but then we've got these other districts
but that's one SAU one district and I
would argue that
yes you know when David sod for former
president of right to know New Hampshire
testified before the house a couple of
years ago he held up our SAU spoke to us
he was a resident within our community
and he spoke about the transparency that
held us up as a model because there's
only one piece of confidential
information in in our in our view and
that's the individual health care
choices of an employee which is why we
aggregate the health care experience
not what the cost per plan is but the
individual person's choice but a
person's employment contract and every
other piece of information we have is
always available if someone calls our
office and asks for a copy of my
personal Employment contract to be
emailed to them so they can review it
no problem
you know it's all open to the public
with the exception of personal health
care choices
so I would argue that transparency
exists and public input is taken and the
large number of elected board members we
have to build and adopt a budget in a
public process
more than handles the concerns that
people may have
thank you very much
not see any other hands thank you very
much thank you for your time yes
good morning good afternoon that's your
wish but close enough thank you very
much my name is Paul deschane I'm a
problem a project manager with the town
of Newington and I've been asked on
behalf of the board of selectman of
knowington to appear before you to speak
about Senate Bill 155 although I'm not
prepared to necessarily answer any
questions relative to the bill as
presented I am suggesting or at the
behalf of the board to contemplate an
amendment in that amendment is on the
backside of the material I just sent you
also should have received this via email
uh the town of Newington finds itself in
a perplexion situation
um in regards to the SAU seu 50 by which
it belongs and
um that part
um
perplexing point is that uh as we
understand the statute has drafted
currently we're not permitted to talk
about necessarily changing uh with our
memory communities and as participants
the methodology by which we fund our SAU
there is a process under RSA
94c2 that speaks to creating a planning
committee and that planning committee is
authorized to discuss a reorganization
of the SAU or draws establishments
operations constructions the facilities
and then possibly curricula but it does
not permit the discussion of funding and
the reason being is because of the
statute
um
that's being contemplated being amended
today
94c9 2
prescribes that the method by which saus
are funded is half on the membership's
attendance and half on the assessed
value of the member of communities
that's it it's at the top down
definitive statement
um the town of Newington would like to
enter a conversation with our member
communities about alternate means of
funding that so hence the red line uh
sentence or phrase we're proposing to
add uh to to the bill if you are so
inclined I would note that if you look
at the Cooperative School District
statute 195 7 subsection 1C
there is a language of this some other
formula offered by The Cooperative
school district school board with the
board's recommendation adopted by the
Corpus school district and approved by
the State Board of Education so
Department of school districts have that
ability
but for some reason saus do not we're
locked into this one half one half
funding mechanism now why is that
important um
many communities feel unjustly uh harmed
by this that edict in the statute in
newington's case 36 percent of our
assessed value is in utilities
utility is already paying the full boat
of the Statewide education tax the 6.60
cents originally done over 10 years ago
uh as compared to the 1.27 that the rest
of the community uh pays so there
their harm is is Amplified because not
only do they have to pay the 660. but
now because Newington has a higher
evaluation than many of its SAU members
it has a disproportional share of the
cost in supporting SAU so we would like
to have at least the ability to discuss
with our members that unfairness and to
see if there's a way to resolve it I'll
leave it at that thank you very much are
thank you thank you
good morning members of the House
Education committee my name is Eric
power I'm the president of the school
district governance Association of New
Hampshire
I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about sau's so
um just for clarity there are 81 single
District saus in New Hampshire and 24
multi-districts you heard the examples
of both of them today every single SAU
has to file what they call this form
a12d central office Personnel that
identifies who's in their SAU no matter
what kind of SAU you are that has to go
to the Department of Education it talks
about full-time equivalence so stay so
everybody has to do this already
uh in a single District SAU the
budgeting process is a little bit
different than a multi-district in a
single District SAU
they it's kind of like they can do
whatever they want because they they
basically their SAU budget is part of
their operating budget I've not seen an
example in a single District Su where
they break out
that is a separate award article
um and it varies greatly in a review of
about a dozen of these single district
saus there were some that cleanly broke
out SAU costs but many about three
quarters did not they rolled salaries
into with all the rest of the salaries
of old benefits and other things so you
couldn't actually tell and they used
different examples I have it in the
testimony that you have different
categories that I that were found in the
review
so in some in many cases it's not clear
how much is being spent on the SAU
office in multi-district sau's they have
to figure out how much is in the seu
it's by law because they have to
apportion
the expenses across the SAU so they
already know so the multi District sau's
already are doing this
they have to do a process to set the SAU
budget it starts in the fall they have
to set a budget in December they have a
hearing and then the SAU board approves
it and you can't change it after that so
that's what happens in a multi-district
SAU
if you've adopted this alternative
budget procedure 194 c9b you can have a
what they call an adjusted budget
similar to a default budget it's
um if they're if they don't have adopted
that then it just becomes a district
the alternative budget procedure is
available but it's only available to the
24 multi-district sau's for one thing
and currently it's only been adopted by
three that's currently in effect
um but what it does do is it provides a
choice between a proposed SAU budget and
a Def and an adjusted budget for all the
voters so all the voters in each of the
district meetings whether it's sb2 or
traditional vote on this and then the
the each is as each meeting happens the
the uh results are announced and then
they're tallied at the end
majority wins
if the majority chooses the proposed
budget you get the proposed budget if it
doesn't you get the default budget
it's difficult to adopt this alternative
budget procedure because you have to
have typically it comes from citizens so
it's a Citizens petition warrant article
in every District
and they um
it's easier for a school board to
um we've already heard about current
education spending Trends I'll skip that
but the idea here is that
requiring budget the budget and
balloting procedure to be used for all
school districts really ensures that all
school districts and especially single
District sau's make it clear to the
voters how much they're spending
and that gives voters a choice
they uh there there was talk about extra
efforts yes there's a little bit of
extra effort but you already know who's
in your SAU because you have to file
that form with the Department of
Education
so the multi-districts are already doing
this the 24 doing 81 aren't
so by providing this this budget process
to all sau's it's going to be more uh
transparent it's going to give voters in
a choice when they have the ballot vote
at their district meeting and when
there's more scrutiny on the budget you
tend to have more responsible and
sustainable budgets
and I also mentioned I'm in it's one of
the school districts that has this
alternative budget procedure so I can
speak to it in detail if anybody has any
questions
so I'd recommend that the house
education committee take a look at this
bill
read the testimony I'd also mention some
of the testimony that's online talks
from single District saus they talk
about how they can't separate the costs
but the the multi-districts are already
doing this so there's a little bit of
discontinuity there
so I would recommend OTP and SB 155 and
I'd be happy to take any questions thank
you are there any questions from the
committee yes representative Tanner
thank you
um I when you started out you said
you're you're president of the I believe
the school district governance
Association of New Hampshire could you
and and are you a lobbyist for them and
uh could you just explain a little bit
about
who they represent
so the school district government
Association is a non-profit New
Hampshire non-profit group nobody is
paid we're all volunteers so we're not
lobbyists if we're not paid
um there's there's 50 uh 55 to 60
members across the state
and they are
former school board members and former
budget committee members or current
school and budget committee members
including about uh 15 or 16 state
representatives
so we advocate for responsible
governance prudent budgeting and
educational excellence in New Hampshire
thank you it's it's my understanding
that being paid or not paid is not uh
criteria for uh
difference between the lobbyist and a
citizen coming and talking to us but
thank you
are there questions from the committee
well yes representative Lino thanks so
so I guess I don't understand why aren't
you wearing an orange badge
lobbyists are people that are paid
that's the law
so and follow up on that so I I is is
this Defiance of worrying orange badge
is this transparent to members of the
public that might want to know if
there's a question regarding that that
can be taken up after the meeting okay
or with the Secretary of State's office
that wherever you choose to go that's
correct but let's stick to the bill okay
thank you Mr chair thank you you're more
than welcome represent cordelli yes I
just want to disclose I'm a member of
the sdga
further further questions from the
committee thank you very much
foreign
good afternoon everyone Mr chairman
thank you my name is Scott Rose I am the
business administrator for sau19
represents Goffstown in New Boston
multi-district
um when I heard about this bill and then
I read through it as somebody who has to
deal with this day to day you asked
before what are the financial impacts
what are the administrative impacts I'm
here for any questions you may have but
I will share with you that I interpret
this text and I have to apply it each
and every day every single law and this
particular change of legislation is
extremely confusing
um to me so I'm going to clarify for a
few things
um one it talks about a default type
budget
not really defined or contracts ensuing
and that is on let me see whatever page
that I'm trying to get the page that was
well the dra helps determine what's in
the default there are statutes that
determine what's in the default
currently on a school district
um if it's a contract that has to be
approved by the legislative body not
just simply by a contract that I have
but this is unclear what I have
contracts with each and every secretary
in the SAU assistant superintendent
facilities director you name it so that
would be part of a default going forward
I don't I don't know does a contract
with a fuel company for two years
constitute a contract don't know and
it's a somewhat ambiguous so you're
asking me as the business administrator
to uphold the laws that you create but
there's just not a whole lot of clarity
um in my role there's a lot of gray
in this particular statute and I the
gentleman behind me had mentioned about
one half ADM one app equalized assessed
valuation well that's kind of easy so
when I do the approp the uh the
allocation of expenses I can follow a
formula pretty simple on this one not so
simple and a lot of it is subject to
interpretation my interpretation and
every other business administrator in
the state of New Hampshire so that's uh
again very very complicated I don't know
if the Department of Revenue has been
involved in this I have to post all of
my
um forms on the dra website is this
going to be on that or are they have
they been consulted on this bill I don't
know I don't know if the New Hampshire
education department has been involved
in this there are legal consequences of
this you look at the um issue of ballots
and that's my second one so I am in also
an election official in Goffstown just
did that two nights ago it was up until
one in the morning
and what I can tell you is that this is
also really problematic
um I don't I can't even determine if I'm
reading it twice whether or not is it
the majority of votes in each individual
town have to pass in both towns or is it
the majority of all towns
um in the statute it talks about a
weighted vote for sau's
um for the SAU board so in my community
Goffstown pays 78 percent of the
appropriation New Boston pays 22 if
there was ever an issue they could take
a weighted vote I can't recall the last
time they've done that except for maybe
20 years ago does the same weighted vote
principle apply here in the in the
election because arguably Goffstown is
paying 78 percent of the freight but yet
if half the voters if the voters in say
New Boston decide that they're not in
favor of it is that fair
don't know ambiguous
um so I think this is another one of
these bills quite honestly that is just
really needs a whole lot more work
respectfully
um and I think in hearing all the
testimony sometimes working groups are
better if you're if you're looking for
transparency maybe there's other ways of
doing that you'll want more local
control maybe other ways of doing this
but I would respectfully ask that
um that you take a pass on this bill and
um not not approve it so thank you very
much thank you very much are there
questions from the committee
now see you thank you very much thank
you
thank you for allowing me back I'll try
to behave better this time
um
yeah oh man it must be in the gene pool
huh oh yeah we're trouble we're trouble
um we are a uh I worked in a
Newfoundland I've worked at NSC 36 both
Cooperative boards uh and uh when I
first started working at boat we were a
single district and we brought on
Dunbarton
sort of former SAU budget in November we
have an SAU meeting where we propose
that budget anyone can come to that
meeting the SAU board is composed of the
full members of the Dunbarton and
billboard so that's 10 members and we
sit and we go over the budget there is
very little money in that budget you
know people keep asking me hey Dr Kevin
you buy this for me I don't have any
money
we have a 36 million dollar budget
between dunbart and Bo the SAU is 1.3
million it supports seven people
the superintendent the business
administrator the special ed director
the curriculum director
Rose who comes in on Wednesdays does all
our books and and two secretaries that's
it
we're in the high school so we don't put
we don't have any building costs or
anything like that and you know you're
talking and we're we're a regular town
meeting in both districts we don't do
default budgets and and you're taking an
alternative
methodology and saying everyone's got to
do the alternative methodology why if
you want to do this methodology you can
adopt it and you can go forward with it
on a larger scale you know I like
talking about larger scales you're all
Representatives
you've been duly elected and people
trust you to make good decisions
that's the same as a school board
they're duly elected they're trusted to
make good decisions if you don't like
the decision your school board is making
vote them out the next time you have an
election
the idea that the only way that we can
control costs is to put it out or for
direct democracy goes against what this
country is founded on we're not a direct
democracy we're a representative
Republic I think I got that right I
wasn't a history major but we're
representative and if you don't like the
decisions that are being made in your
local school board then vote them out
and get someone else in there so we have
that that 10-member meeting in November
we propose the budget uh it's put out on
our website you don't even have to find
it it's right there you can go through
it pretty transpire we got seven people
put their names on everything that
happens and then we adopt the budget in
December usually with very few changes
and then we apportion it out to the two
districts and we start talking about the
36 million so let's talk about this
concept of default year to year
one employee changes in my office and
goes from a wave Insurance to a family
insurance that's about a twenty thousand
dollar change
I don't have twenty thousand dollars to
find in our budget because we have
contracts with everyone else there and
so we have to be very careful about that
sort of thing the way we budget we're
lucky that saus are allowed to carry
over a fund balance year to year uh
you're not in your District but your SCU
is the seu has been prudently budgeting
to make sure that they're able to take
care of things the other big thing in
our SAU budget is the is the legal
budget you know we have to hire our
lawyers for um negotiations and so forth
I mean if you have a year where you have
a bunch of negotiations or you get sued
on something that legal budget goes up
and and you've got to find it within
your SAU budget there just isn't a whole
lot of room
so I don't understand what the need for
this is you know I'm North Country it's
not broken don't fix it I mean what what
are you trying to fix you can already
adopt this process if you want to in the
present law and you know if you want to
know what's happening in your seu budget
call the seu and at least in my district
I'm not sure if everyone else is usually
I'll direct you to a part on our website
where the budget is posted
and the last thing is local control we
seem to like local control a lot but
only in certain cases your your school
board is elected by the community they
make great decisions and I tell you the
seu budget gets a lot more scrutiny than
any other budget because it's so small
everyone knows exactly what it's going
for
done
thank you very much are there any
questions
thank you very much
and I don't have any other pink cards on
155 so with that I'm going to close this
hearing
yes
so so as a committee what we'll do it
because we've canceled the one o'clock
to another day 272.
uh but we do want to put a little bit of
time to start talking about the side by
sides we got for 266 so we'll start that
a quarter after one and go for about a
half hour to get some kind of a course
in organization to where we're going to
go and how we're going to handle it and
then we'll stop at uh at the at the next
hearing which files and that should be
it for the day yeah
okay
and we're in a work session right now
and the work session is for 266 and
we have a side by side we have several
actually and I want to thank Jennifer
for doing that I know that took hours
and hours of work
days and days
and and so we have one that shows you
the it looks at the current law and the
version as introduced
and some notes in the side there's
another one
which is
uh has a lot of reference to numbers and
lines and all that and identifies
correct me if I'm wrong Jennifer but the
areas which are highlighted are darker
are areas that are not reflected are
missed
yeah you didn't see it there okay so
that will you know attract us to it as
well
yeah
yeah it's you'll see that in the back of
that document where the indicators of
the delivery of an adequate education
located 193e
um three
and so let's let's first look at the one
which is the current law
and the version as introduced we'll
we'll walk through that and get a little
bit done here and maybe we'll get into
the process that you know that we'll be
following and this is not going to be
a quick deal this is going to take some
time that's why we need to start this
in terms of minutes I understand they
and so that that's remarkable that
so smart I guess right yeah
you should learn strategy
we should get help with him yeah uh-huh
so let's look at page one there or we
see on 193 C colon one the statement of
purpose for this section of Law and for
266.
it says on the right this section is a
identical in both versions so I don't
think that's neat that we address that
page one it looks you know and and I I
read through it I know Jen has done the
same thing
so everything that's in the law is in
this version as it's written in law
currently
then we go to page three and we start to
see some things which I think will you
know cause some questioning
the term at the top of Page Three where
it says committee means the legislative
oversight committee established to
review the Statewide education
Improvement and Assessment program
that's been removed
does it make a difference one way or the
other I don't know but we're talking
about us the legislative oversight
committee and if that's removed
somewhere
and
when it
when things start moving from one
chapter to another chapter I ask why is
it easier to read is it easier to follow
or is it meaning that you're not
um so it's something we need to look at
it
the end size I understand that
in size meets the students sample size
necessary disclose or display data to
ensure maximum student group visibility
that's it's a it's a term that's used
commonly
then as you slide down a little bit
you'll see academic standards
now everybody knows the academic
standards have to be approved by the
State Board of Education along with the
minimum standards for public school
approval have to be approved by the
state board
but if you also look what are the
responsibilities of legislative
oversight
they have the responsibility for
bringing by any recommendations or
changes regarding the
um accuracy it's the academic standards
I I'm trying to remember
the academic stems has come to us
the minimum standards I don't think it's
clearly written
in our oversight responsibilities or
duties
question Rick yes
how did we know whether they may win the
academic standards are supposed to be
measures at the end of the grade level
or
during the Great loving is it to get
into that grade or you get out of that
grade
well
academic standards mean what a student
should know and be able to do and a
course well but see if we're dealing
with the language we have right here
yeah because we're not rewriting the
whole thing we're just going through and
seeing what they've done but you notice
they're talking about grade level
do you have instruction and curriculum
at the high school in terms of grade
level or in terms of course
yes you got it and course is missing
my question to him is why
we put that in we the legislature put
that in
few years back
we recognize that you know the
I'd be curious if there's any comment
regarding that because it's a it could
so so I highlighted that one myself
since as something we ought to be
looking at check it off
um then they're also not calling them
academic standards they're calling them
Statewide academic standards
right
is that a clearer
definition
or is that a confusing definition now
what's different between academic
standards and Statewide academically
we have had so many definitions using
the word standards that's very confusing
we have a choice about using some other
academic standard than the Statewide
standards
that's true
so like what other academic standard and
why wouldn't we just use the state line
once
what's the purpose so that this raises a
question yeah so that's another thing we
ought to be checking off for we we
wonder about that so it goes down
through this you can see almost there's
going to be this type of discussion just
about in every page we're going to go to
yeah
on testing entity
yeah is there a question there
they put we had under RSA 193 C's colon
six so we gotta look through that area
that's gone
they couldn't make it here so it's I
think it's wise that we go through so
that's right they they'll give us
technical advice or support when we need
okay
adds a reference to oversight committee
proposed to be moved to chapter 193 e
oh that's that was in the remember in
the definition yeah so where it was
moved to the east yeah and now they're
we just gotta keep it up here so we can
um if you go to page four
SB 2266 changes open-ended performance
tasks to other item types identified by
department and testing entity as
necessary as Jen has written
you noticed right there on the current
side under Roman 2 there's a c
these are assessed assessment
instruments we use to identify
where the uh somebody's measuring up to
those minimum competencies
and we know there's the Statewide
assessment there's other ways of doing
it as well
yeah
open space assessment and that's what
that is
fast so they're taking up
interesting
student
they use this term testing entity what's
that mean what does it mean
s
whoever they contract with for the state
okay so if they contract with say I
don't know measured progress
that would be the entity for testing
okay now you you recall when we had Pace
yes Pace districts that that we had
peace districts and that was Yeah Austin
you want me to see what the pace means
that was when pbass first yeah was being
tested out it was another way that a
number of districts were were looking at
competencies and as as representative
Cascadian be able to test out of that
and move to the next level yeah of of
Competency without having to have the
Statewide assessment do that number for
them we had to get approval from the
federal government to do that yeah in
our waiver yeah there were eight uh
eight districts in the past yeah that
was that pilot yeah
rationally no no
development of October so does that
program still offering
I I don't remember
I don't I don't know I mean there's no
oversight I mean there's no leadership
foreign
but see though they've got other item
types identified
I don't know what that really means is
that some other kind of a test or is
that a a some kind of a portfolio or
some kind of a performance of some kind
uh
since that's that type of multiple
choice yes
to
Notch it kind of open-ended performance
passed but that would open it up to like
portfolio yeah I was just thinking that
see in that would be like an essay
question
yeah yeah
yeah I just wrote down other performance
tasks to appropriately measure learning
measure student learning
um
but it's Marine Corps schools other
performance tasks
yeah other performance tasks which is a
broader ability for you to develop
locally as to what you want to use to
measure
but some systems use things that don't
have solutions to test your response to
a set of crises or criteria or whatever
and there is no solution they want to
see how you respond to it
put a grade on that
foreign
I was concerned on this academic
standards Roman 3 there a
academic standards specifying what
students should know and be able to do
shall be clearly defined before
assessment procedures and exercises are
developed that's been put in into law
here ever since
um they're writing Statewide academic
standards established by the department
in consultation with Educators and
stakeholders
which shall be used to identify grade
level expectations and standardized cut
scores
we also have in law later on and
receiving prior review and
recommendation of the legislative
oversight committee
that's in the the bill we just passed
this last year
so page three was easy
well notice it says Who develops it the
department
well it does say what stakeholders yeah
I think that historically that's been
part of the practice I think of bringing
the teachers and administrators in to
deal with it so yeah they talked about
that the other day the standards which
were approved the Next Generation
science standards had to receive
approval from the legislative oversight
committee
and this is excluding that group that's
Christian isn't the same reading
proficiency here is it the same as
reading Proficiency in Mississippi
well they they set those they set the
bar
like proficiency one versus proficiency
two
Etc
out in the communities think proficient
things pass
the feds do have one two three four
right
but they they have minimum levels
minimum bars for example the minimum bar
for graduation
I believe it's
60 or 67 percent of kids graduating from
high school
our graduation rate is close to 89 90
percent
but we're using their bar because that's
the bar they use for Essa
the every student succeeds act it's it's
the elementary secondary Education Act
we did
and and because it has to move every
year or it's supposed to move up you
know one of those the proficiencies
thing is supposed to move up so as you
make it you never catch up you know some
people have never told me we were saying
how
if we're at 91 and the bar federally is
like at 67 you know making us move up to
92 or 93 is is a lot tougher than ever
it's it's just like in the CTA
representative Cornell where we have
allocated nine million dollars each and
now we're going to 11. that is our
maintenance of effort now will always
have to be at least 11 million we can't
go down
if we want to get the federal money
so you have to maintain your maintenance
of effort and the same thing applies to
these scores you raise that bar you're
not going to go back down
so they put the minimum bar in our
statutes
but it's not reflective of the Granite
State 67 graduation I don't know how
they do one two three or four though I
as a um standards that that we had
because I that I thought that we didn't
take the enrollment probably
we had a higher borrowing that that was
part of the problem that had improved
I can remember Senator guy to going off
his nut on that because he wanted it
higher yeah yeah yeah and uh no we kept
it that low bar because
Federal money
the final that's a state plan is is
I had another note on that question that
we're looking at
in the current law it says what students
should know and my emphasis anything
that you do
and in the draft that language is taken
out
I mean it shouldn't just be that you
have knowledge it should be that you're
so what we're doing is just building
some awareness right now so when we do
sit down with them
we have some talking points already
um
yeah we're down at the bottom page four
right now and
I think we can skip over to page five
and
they're putting in to improve
unless there's something
I don't really have a gut ache on any of
that
on Page Six
you look at item I
and they're taking out
the part that basically
we have taken out in finance
the the differentiated aid for third
grade reading
my question is though
um should we have the part that says at
the end of the grade three to determine
that people sorry should we have that
right down to where on the middle there
it says Department as part of a
Statewide Assessment program period
and leaving the differentiate Aid stuff
out
right so what you're saying is only
remove the money part of it yeah
we would still be assessing we want to
assess that's exactly right that third
graders that's where the Statewide
so I was just scratching out that latter
but you've got to have an assessment
unless you're not going to
is the reading this assessment
the 19840.
okay yeah
yeah so did we just take the latter part
of that sends out and leave referencing
to the third grade testing in
it's and I was wondering why if you're
with us Jen where it says this section
okay because one says shall one says May
the State Board of Education shall adopt
rules
and the other side the State Board of
exemption yeah
the second line
so the question asked do we need rules
or does the statutory language say it
well enough is that is that where they
said there were no rules they shall and
they haven't
they had never developed they just go by
the statue yeah right and if you go by
Statue you get it done quicker you know
rule making gel car is a long process so
but it might be a question mark when we
have a chance to have Nate in here we
to make sure things are
functions
yeah
uh we have about three more minutes here
Senator Waters came in to help us
um
the next part there is the part which
the components the areas that make up
when I first came in the legislature
it went
mathematics science and
those other areas as a requirement of
the state assessment now because we
weren't doing it history geography
civics economics
well we gave it to the local to make the
decision
how they were going to do that right
there's no Statewide assessment for
those areas
so I don't know
a place but I think there should be
assessment thinking about yesterday
yesterday's when you know Senator Carson
Senator dalessandro were in here it gave
cost for us to really start thinking
so maybe that maybe this is a good place
to stop right now because we're going to
go into that but so we're going to need
this set up a day
to go through this and it's so if if
everybody's able to try and look at
these things
and to you know find things which may be
of you know concern
I've gone through and I've found places
you know
just like we found the other day that
the word competencies
that are in statute are not is not the
same definition they're putting a new
ed306 rules
so there's there's not going to be a
reference back
no
okay so we'll close the work session
right here and we'll set it up on the
it's going to be a little bit here we
can't do it next week of course because
we we haven't put it in the calendar
and the following week
let's see next week is the budget
getting it over right
and then the following week we're going
to have to exec some of our bills which
we have
yeah
so it's going to be somewhere either
possibly in that week or the week after
we'll start this this could take several
days
yeah yeah who selects vendors
the skateboard does
have we got any new bills for uh today
and there were no bills for education on
the regular calendar
and there were just now consent
yeah
um
okay we have a bill right now uh that
we're needing to go in in the hearing
process
you do
yourself
okay
more accomplished okay
so we're looking at SB 213
relative to educational institution
policies on social media
and I'd like to welcome Senator Waters
through education thank you very much Mr
chair Mr Vice chairman members of the
committee Senator David Waters District
Ford introduce some
Senate bill 213.
um this bill makes a couple of small
changes to our social media
and student use
statutes and um it arises from some
information we began to receive last
summer from Educators and also
conversations we had with doe and with
the Career and Technical education
advisory Council and so worked during
the fall
and up until really just a couple days
ago to come up with some language about
it and there's really two parts here let
me explain them separately the first
part of the bill
but let me just actually let me say a
word about social media policy
um some of us in the room were here a
number of years ago
um when we did the work on social uh
media policy uh in part because of a of
a need to tighten up and to make sure
we're accounting for the new
technologies and also quite tragically
some situations in a couple of schools
where social media had been related to
some abuse so we you know we I think we
really worked very
uh very well in the house of Senator
crafts some really good legislation uh
as time has gone by it's clear we need
to tweak it a little bit for a couple
reasons um the first part here
um really you uh might think of it as
the LinkedIn Amendment
um that there are students who are
preparing to have credentials they can
present so they can get certification or
employment and uh superintendents and
others were saying well no no under the
policies that they sought in statute we
couldn't let students under the
supervision of teachers use LinkedIn so
they couldn't get their credentials out
on that platform potentially other ones
um the second one
comes more particularly related to
Career and Technical education that
there are several curricular platforms I
think particularly in edu in engineering
um but also uh accelerated by the covet
epidemic in areas like welding and an
auto repair where there's really good
online curriculum available but we need
to make a change to our statute uh about
allowing that under teacher supervision
and with parental consent
because some superintendents were
reading our existing statute to say no
even though it seemed to me then the
statute existing that they are we could
hardly do that but they will look into
different area statute and saying we
don't think we can do it so that this
will clarify that Authority and um so
you'll see here uh in the existing
version of paragraph two that being
addressed I had to send to
electronically since we passed this in
the Senate doe came forward and said we
really think that we need to make just a
couple changes in the warning in part
two and I think rather importantly put
it in into
189 66
rather than in 189.70.
and partly the reason for that is to
make sure that we are very clear on the
requirement of parental consent for
opt-in
and that's the section of Statute where
that this belongs then and um we think
this is really essential that we have a
parental opt-in specified uh here
written parental consent
um
so what the it will now read on part two
and again I we emailed it to you in the
the chair has a few copies
um students participating in career
exploration
or Career and Technical education May
with written parental consent register
for technology platforms and services to
be used as part of the students program
and study and that's important too it's
not just for any other reason it's
because they've got to use that
engineering curriculum or that
Automotive or whatever it might be or a
lot of the biological sciences too which
require the provision of personally
identifiable information copies of
written parental consent shall be
retained as part of a student's
educational record
um so uh this has been a I'm really
appreciative to the attorneys at the
Department of Education who brought
forward
these issues and the way to deal with
them and here's the Bill thank you Mr
chairman uh Senator Waters I I received
a communication from Jeff beard
and I'll read it and then you can tell
me is this amendment addressing what
Jeff is saying here
he says I agree and if it is possible
amending RSA 18966 would address the
issue we've discussed of CTE teachers
and students finding it difficult to
access industry recognized credential
Assessments in Industry standard tools
such as Adobe Pro and SolidWorks in the
CTE programs so does this amendment take
care of what the director is saying yes
and what um thanks for your question
what um Jeff beard did was he took that
to the attorney
in Department of Education who drafted
it this way to account for for that and
to make sure we have the written
parental consent so what you see before
you is what the deal we attorney and
commissioner aw signed off on
are there questions of Senator Waters
I would just think that um I'll take a
look but I think we also have in line
with this amendment have to take a look
at 189 68a which deals with online
personal information and systems which
require personal information
I think we have to
check that section also thank you yes
yes represent McDonald thank you Mr
chair thank you Senator Waters line
seven of the bill mentions Career
Development could you speak a little bit
more as to what careers your the intent
of the bill is trying to include
I'm sorry which part of are you
referencing
line seven specifically Career
Development yeah like just which careers
yeah
um
I think that that was um
done
relatively generically of that phrase so
that we didn't say LinkedIn or some of
the other platforms that are used by
particular fields that you'd want to
demonstrate
your student Career Development and what
this what these essentially do is that
it lets you
um say I had took this course took this
course took this course that these are
the ones that we use to qualify me for
getting this credential or forgetting
that job so that's why that the first
phrase that way I think you know doe who
created this language can perhaps
explain a little more educational ease
why this is the way to go but it was
meant to be fairly clear that it's
student Career Development so this is
why it's related to credentialing and
other other things but without being so
specific that we delimited what
platforms might be useful for a given
field could I ask a follow-up go ahead
is there anything within this build that
would prevent a student who thinks they
could perhaps be developing a career
such as a influencer on social media new
ideas some students have is there
anything in this bill that would prevent
them from doing that because it's not
School related but they might believe
it's School related or will develop
their career and
some kind of
well it's a unique way I guess yeah an
extra question let's you know you know
work with representative Kirk and
Senator Reagan and and I kind of really
worked on these because I you know
protecting our students is Paramount to
me yes and let's consider and
Vice chair cordelli rightly saying let's
look make sure we button it up with 168.
is that this is under supervision
and a smooth parental consent so those
questions will be asked well what
exactly what job you're going to apply
for what credential you're going to get
and if there are legitimate
credentialings in those in those areas
that's what's appropriate here if if
there aren't then they can go do that at
home
but as far as demonstrating educational
accomplishment
these are the controls all right thank
you that answers the question
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you Senator
Waters um I just wanted to address the
sort of underlying idea here of
utilizing
um such as social media platforms for
career development can you speak to
whether or not there's any cause for
concern that if we're going to possibly
Advance students using particular social
media platforms to act as sort of
accumulators of their individual skill
sets in order to try to get employment
could we not be
disadvantaging students who don't want
to use those in creating a bit of a
perverse incentive there that students
have to use these sites in order to be
competitive
well that's the question I I think this
is essentially enabling of a student or
their parent says no
that's where that's where it is what
what I was concerned with this one is
that you know being deeply invested in
career and Tech education and in
Workforce and providing opportunities
for our for our high school students
that um we don't have something that
prevents them from being able to post
their credentials or to access things
that would be would help them with an
employer or help them with their
certification so I you know I I uh I
worry about that I in that you know we
want to make sure students have the
opportunity but it is finally A Parent's
Choice isn't it or a student's choice if
they don't want to do something we it
just doesn't force them
just real quick just to clarify I just
want to make sure because I I'm not
familiar with the entirety of this law
there's nothing in current law that
would prohibit a student or parents from
doing that on their own is there
uh no but you know if you're some of
this these educational
um curricula you're using in the school
okay Adobe or
um I mean there's some amazing things
that came out of covert where you can do
medical procedures online with you know
virtual reality or work on a car
um but then the engineering one is
there's a really great some really great
quick home out there okay thank you so
anyways
description of cordelli thank you
Senator Waters do you know if this would
um whereby a person gets a digital badge
and you get
um badges included in your folder for
certain performance tasks or
certifications or so forth because I I
have concerns about digital badging and
have had it on my list for a couple of
years to look at legislation in that
regard because of uh concerns about
um
you don't necessarily know who's posting
a badge for you being able to
object to something or modify something
Etc I think or issues to be looked at
with digital badging so I'm not sure if
really this would Encompass digital
badging or not I don't know if that has
come up in any conversations you've had
on this that's a question no it hasn't
and um you know great question and I I'm
not sure whether it's really relevant
particularly to this but I think it's a
great question to ask the attorneys or
at or if you ask Jeff beard he'll get it
to the attorneys and and see because
yeah I mean you know here we wrote you
know Neil Kirk and I and John Reagan
wrote a great Bill a few years ago and
then then who to think that social media
changes huh so we gotta we gotta make
sure we're protecting our kids and
keeping up yeah now you're hanging about
AI
I could use some of that artificial
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um
when when some of the the the
clamp down on using social media
happened in in schools
um I had quite a conversation with a
local school that I represent and they
do they use uh they have a graphic
design class that they use Adobe they
had a drafting class where they used
online drafting tools uh things like
that and when that law went through they
thought they couldn't use them and it
seems and so I appreciate that you have
this bill coming through I'm just
wondering if if uh it sounds like you're
the whole purpose or the whole
um Initiative for this bill was through
the Career and Technical the CTE centers
and I'm just thinking uh could
uh the public schools that have uh that
want to use Adobe use the same type in
it for a career uh the same type of
thing with teacher supervision with uh
parent
um opt-in on that that's the question
and I I think that you know I I did
speak about ctes but this is meant to be
a little broader than that that's why on
line eight career exploration or career
in technical education
um
and uh the the example you gave is just
the problem that some superintendents
were looking at the statute which we had
thought allowed them their students to
use the curriculum they wanted and
they're looking at the statute and
saying well you look over here and we're
a little nervous about it so basically
this is it's not housekeeping bill but
basically what it does is to make sure
especially by going into
um
66 instead of 70. we think that this
addresses the concerns the
superintendents were having over what
was permissible
thank you
further questions from the committee yes
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you just um
technical question
is this amendment the only part of the
amendment or is this just to amend the
amendment
um if you uh look at the the original
Bill yep
um as passed by the as amended by the
Senate
um
paragraph two the amendment just
replaces that part but the first part is
still in the first few lines are still
in the bill yeah so it says Amendment
bill by replacing section two with the
following so just that just that second
an option Damon
thank you thank you for taking my
question
I'm just wondering in the amendment has
left out what in the bill from the
Senate is the end of line 13 and 14. so
such technology and services shall have
a direct connection to the content areas
of study that seems like a valuable
statement yeah thinking that that's
covered because it says it's part of the
um
yes uh what we thought was that by
moving into this other section
and by including
um
in line three of the amendment data
inventory and policies publication
um that that line was no longer
necessary
so this is what this is what the
attorney at the doe said we we've got it
covered now that line is no longer
necessary
because you know it's where we have
areas of study
um and uh they want a program of study
on line seven so they said by making
program study it that is what replaces
such technology direct connection to the
content areas of study and this actually
tightens it up a bit my same program
study instead of areas because areas
gets kind of loose so that that's that's
why that that's why attorney did it the
are there further questions from the
committee for Senator Waters
thank you so much Mr chairman remember
is there any I I don't have any other
pink cards here
is there any more information that may
be needed on this
for us to gather and and be looking at
this amendment to
does the department have anything for us
Diana no no
okay
so with that in the CTE advisory Council
I know the CTE centers have been
complaining about this the whole time
I've been there because they can't
access the students can't access what
they need to
especially sometimes if they've gone
through the whole program and then they
can't access it to get their credential
so it's been a big problem and I think a
lot of it's been the I.T directors in
the in the districts too have had a
problem with it so and this will be very
helpful
yeah
okay so with that if there's no more
discussion yes well we're not into a
discussion there's no but he also wants
to present I guess you know our hearing
the hearing is going to be closed
if if you want to talk a little bit
about this later we can
um okay so with that I'm going to close
the hearing on on SBE 213 so that closes
that is there anybody had a question
about that bill though or wants to
discussed a little bit are we good
yeah
I would just
the the part in the bold letters here is
kind of flashing red signals for me
because it seems to me that just knowing
the way things tend to work if we enable
social media companies to begin
collecting these these pieces of
information for students that are then
going to be trying to use for employment
purposes that that that's going to place
these students entirely at the mercy of
these social media companies when it
comes to trying to obtain employment and
that opens the door to all sorts of
control mechanisms that I don't think we
okay so there's one you know perspective
that we might want to consider
um
is there any way you could rewrite that
Diana could you convey to Jeff that
there may be some concern with that line
six seven and the bill
mm-hmm
okay I guess with that we are done for
today
yeah the 11th would be the
next scheduled meeting I haven't
chairman Ladd yeah a question do you
know how many more Senate bills we have
for our public hearings the the bills
which we have are the ones that we
scheduled for today and the other day
right so with that there's two bills
that we haven't heard one from last
night yesterday afternoon and then 272.
that's it
that's it that's enough but I I was like
expecting a whole other day so what we
would do so now once we get those done
we exactly
and then what we do is we look it's you
know we won't be doing 266 until we have
more work groups on that then we exec
and after we finish doing that we're
going to be looking at the retained
bills which we have
and we got to go back to those and I can
tell you how many retaining bills we
we don't really have to act on them
until the fall not till the fall but if
there's some retain bills which we want
to have work sessions for subgroups
committee groups that's when we set
those up and stride it start working on
good afternoon
sure